ओके
सो आई थिंक कम लाइव नाउ लेट मी चेक वंस
गाइस जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट जस्ट
वेट चलिए
तो वी आर लाइव राइट आई थिंक आई एम ऑडिबल
एंड विजिबल क्लीयरली प्लीज लेट मी न गाइस
लेट मी चेक वंस एक बार देख लेता हूं मैं
थोड़ा सा वेट कीजिए एक बार मैं देख लेता
हूं लाइ
लाइव ओके सो गा एम ऑडिबल एंड विजिबल
क्लियर है मेरी आवाज मेरी ऑडियो वीडियो सब
सही है प्लीज बता दीजिए एक
बार मैंने अपने साइड से तो चेक कर लिया है
बट आप भी एक बार कंफर्म कर दीजिए ताकि मैं
डबल कंफर्म हो जाऊं आपसे लेट मी सी
माइसेल्फ मैं भी देख लेता
हूं ठीक है आई थिंक एवरीथिंग इज गुड चलिए
हां
जी
ओके राधे राधे भाई राधे राधे चलो यस ओके
चलिए तो स्टार्ट करते हैं गाइस आज का सेशन
हम आज का सेशन बहुत धमाकेदार होने वाला है
स्टार्ट करने से पहले मैं आपको एकदम शॉर्ट
में जल्दी से पहले बता देता हूं हमारा
ट्रैक कर सकते हैं एंड बेसिकली अपने जो भी
डीसी जीएसपी या डीसीएसपी के सर्टिफिकेट्स
है इस पे आके आप वेरीफाई कर सकते हैं एंड
ब्लॉग सेक्शन में आके आप ब्लॉक्स भी पढ़
सकते हैं कुछ अलग-अलग डिफरेंट टॉपिक्स पे
ठीक है चलिए अब अगर आप सबको याद होगा तो
मैंने आप सबको अ एक चीज बताई थी कि हमारे
जो डिक्स अकेडमी चैनल पे क्लासेस आ रही है
कोर्सेस आ रही है आप सारी को फॉलो कीजिए
बग से पहले अगर आपको याद होगा तो बग बाउंट
से पहले बहुत कुछ हुआ था मैंने बोला था
आपको फॉलो करना है मुझे पता है बाकी जो
चीजें होती है थोड़ी बोरिंग लगती है बहुत
लोग उसको फॉलो नहीं कर रहे होंगे तो मैं
आपको एक बार रिमाइंडर देना चाहता हूं आज
हम जो सेशन में करने वाले हैं जो हम आज हम
जो टॉपिक करने वाले हैं वह बहुत शानदार
टॉपिक है मैं यहां पर आपको दिखा देता हूं
क्या टॉपिक है आपको
पहले बता देता हूं लेट मी गिव अ ब्रीफ ऑफ
द टॉपिक टुडेज टॉपिक आज के टॉपिक का ब्रीफ
दे देता हूं पहले आपको ताकि आपको क्लियर
हो जाए कि आज हम करने क्या वाले हैं चलिए
सभी लोग को आ जाने देते हैं तो आज जो है
ना हम एक बहुत ही कमाल के टूल किट के बारे
में या कमाल के एक टूल के बारे में पढ़ने
वाले हैं जिसका नाम है एन
मैप एन मैप अब यह एन मैप जो हम पढ़ने वाले
हैं ना इसके बारे में अगर आपको नहीं पता
तो मैं आपको एक शॉर्ट सॉरी सॉरी तो मैं
आपको एक शॉर्ट इंट्रो दे देता हूं कि एन
मैप जो टूल है इसको प्रोफेशनली
ऑल ओवर वर्ल्ड में यूज किया जाता है एंड
इसके बिना कोई भी साइबर सिक्योरिटी की
सर्टिफिकेशन अधूरी है कोई से भी आप साइबर
सिक्योरिटी सर्टिफिकेशन की बात करें ए मैप
का रोल वहां आता ही आता है डायरेक्टली और
इनडायरेक्टली दूसरी चीज मिस्टर रोबोट
सीरीज आपने देखी होगी वहां भी ए मैप का
यूज किया जा रहा है रियल यूज किया जा रहा
है एंड ए मैप अपने आप में एक बेसिकली ऑल
इन वन टूल आप बोल सकते हो जिसके यूज करने
के जानकारी के बाद आप बहुत कुछ कर सकते हो
टारगेट के ऊपर एंड बहुत सारी एडिशनल जो अ
चीजें हैं वो कर सकते हो एक टारगेट के ऊपर
में तो बग बाउंडी का यह बहुत ही एक
एसेंशियल स्टेप है एंड एक एसेंशियल टूल है
रिकमेंडेटरी हैंड्स ऑन के कुछ भी नहीं आप
कर पाओगे अगर बात करते हैं स्कैनिंग की
अगर बात करते हैं न्यूमरेशन टारगेट
एन्यूमरेशन की अगर बात करते हैं टारगेट के
सर्विस के बारे में जानने की अगर बात करते
हैं वेब सर्वर को जानने की तो इसके भी
पॉसिबल नहीं है बिल्कुल पॉसिबल नहीं है
चलिए ठीक है अब यहां पे मैं बताता हूं
आपको प्रीवियस जो हमारी बग बाउंट की
क्लासेस हुई हैं ठीक है तो आप प्रीवियस बग
बाउंट की क्लासेस में जो हमारी 15th क्लास
थी 15th वाली ये वाली स्कैनिंग टारगेट्स
फॉर ओपन पोर्ट्स एंड सर्विसेस इसमें मैंने
आपको अलग-अलग टूल्स के बारे में बताए थे
राइट अलग-अलग टूल्स के बारे में हमने देखा
था इस क्लास के अंदर में क्या देखा था
भैया हमने चलिए यहां पे मैं डायरेक्टली
यहां दिखा देता हूं
तो हमने क्लास 15 में क्लास 15 में हमने
क्या देखा था हमने बेसिकली क्लास 15 में
नाबू के बारे नाबू को देखा था मास स्कैन
देखा
था ठीक है रस स्कैन देखा था ठीक यह कुछ
टूल्स देखे थे हम इन टूल्स का यूज क्यों
कर रहे थे हम इन टूल का यूज जो है ना
इसलिए कर रहे थे कि हम यह देख पाए कि
सामने टारगेट के ऊपर पोर्ट्स जो है व ओपन
है क्लोज है या क्या है पोर्ट के स्टेटस
को देखने के लिए पोर्ट्स स्टेटस को देखने
के लिए हम य टूल का यूज कर रहे थे राइट
पोर्ट्स के स्टेटस को ट्स इट हमने इस टूल
का यूज क्यों किया हम एन मैप से भी पोर्ट
के स्टेटस को देख सकते हैं लेकिन जब हम एन
मैप को यूज करेंगे एक लार्ज स्कोप के लिए
लार्ज स्कोप ऑफ पोर्ट्स के लिए वहां पर
एनम थोड़ा फेल हो जाता है और एनम बहुत ही
स्लो काम करता है बहुत स्लो काम करेगा तो
वहां एन मैप यूज नहीं कर सकते इसलिए हमने
नाबू या मास्क स्कैन रस स्टन को यूज किया
जो आपकी प्रोसेस को काफी ज्यादा फास्ट कर
देता है जब आपके पास होस्ट की लिस्ट आ
जाएगी होस्ट की लिस्ट आ जाएगी जिस पर आपको
फर्द स्टेप्स लेने हैं तो आपके लिए वो
ज्यादा इजी हो जाता है जिसपे आप एंड मैप
फिर चलाएंगे सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन के लिए
या फर्द एन्यूमरेशन एक्सप्लोइटेशन इन सब
के लिए सिंपल सा फंडा अब ए मैप का यूज हम
बेसिकली क्यों करने वाले हैं आज के टॉपिक
आज के क्लास में हम क्या इसका यूज होने
वाला है तो एन मैप का हम सॉरी मैं यहां
पर आई थिंक कलर चूज करा हा एन मैप का यूज
हम करने वाले हैं न्यूमरेशन के
लिए ठीक है एन मैप का यूज हम करने वाले
हैं होस्ट डिस्कवरी के
लिए ए मैप का यूज हम करने वाले हैं टू
फाइंड ओपन
पोर्ट्स
ओपन पोर्ट्स एन मैप का यूज हम करने वाले
हैं
सर्विस एंड वर्जन डिटेक्शन में वर्जन
डिटेक्शन में इन सबके लिए हम करने वाले
हैं एंड ओएस डिटेक्शन में भी हम इसका यूज
करने वाले हैं ठीक
है
सॉरी
ओके थैंक यू थैंक यू धन्यवाद चलिए धन्यवाद
सभी लोग का ऐड आ गया है तो मैं थोड़ा वेट
कर लेता हूं बहुत कम लोग हैं आज लाइव में
क्यों बात क्यों क्या बात है भाई आज एन
मैप का सुन के लाइव में कम आए हैं क्या और
जितने लोग आए हैं लाइक ठोक दो जल्दी से
क्योंकि आज का क्लास ना है बहुत लोग बहुत
कुछ सोच के नहीं आए होंगे बट आज का क्लास
सबसे ज्यादा इंटरेस्टिंग होने वाला है वो
लोग मिस करेंगे लाइफ को याद रखिएगा जो लोग
भी हैं जो ये सोच के आए हैं कि एन मैप है
तो दे विल बी मिसिंग बेसिकली टोटल वो मिस
करने वाले हैं बहुत कुछ करने वाले हैं ठीक
है तो हम ये सारी चीजें करने वाले हैं
चलिए अब मैं आपको यहां पे और भी कुछ समझा
देता हूं यहां पे ए
मैप तो एन मैप वाले आज के क्लास में हम
कुछ कुछ टर्म्स को यूज करने वाले हैं जैसे
कि टीसीपी को यूज करेंगे यूडीपी को यूज
करेंगे आईसीएमपी को यूज करेंगे आप में से
कितने लोगों को ये टर्म्स के बारे में पता
है यह सब बताइए मुझे गुड इवनिंग गुड
इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग आप में से कितने लोगों
को इन टर्म्स के बारे में पता है सिन का
यूज करेंगे एसी के फिन या फिर
पुश यह हो गए जो भी है तो हम इन सब चीजों
को यूज करने वाले इन सब टर्म्स को यूज
करने वाले हैं कहीं ना कहीं यूज आने वाला
है आईसीएमपी भी आएगा हां ऊपर लिख दिया
मैंने ठीक है आप में से कितने लोगों को इन
टर्म्स का आईडिया मुझे बताइए जरा लेट मी
नो यस यस यस यस पता है पता है ठीक है
बढ़िया बढ़िया बढ़िया पता है ओके अगर आपको
पता है ट्स
दैट्ची की तरफ आओगे तो नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
की एक सीरीज आपको मिल रही होगी
राइट यस यस यस बिल्कुल
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी की एक सीरीज यहां पे
आपको मिल रही होगी देखिए यहां पे या तो आप
प्लेलिस्ट में चले जाइएगा प्लेलिस्ट में
आप आ जाएंगे तो यहां पे आपको देखिए
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी की एक प्लेलिस्ट दिख
जाएगी ये नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी फ्री
ट्रेनिंग आप इस पे आ जाइएगा एंड इसमें
आपको नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी की ये सारी टोटल
13 वीडियोस के आसपास मिलेंगी इसमें आपको
ये सारे कांसेप्ट बहुत ही अच्छे तरीके से
बताए और समझाए गए हैं आप उनको देख सकते
हैं ठीक है ध्यान रखिएगा एंड आज के सेशन
को देखने से पहले आपसे रिक्वेस्ट है कि आप
कल का सेशन ये जो है ना स्कैनिंग टारगेट्स
फॉर ओपन पोर्ट्स ये जरूर देख लीजिएगा एंड
देन आज का भी सेशन देखिएगा हालांकि थोड़ा
इंडिपेंडेंट होगा बट स्टिल देख लीजिएगा
ज्यादा मजा आएगा
चलिए अब हम यहां पे शुरू करते हैं ए मैप
को
लेके चलिए तो मैंने आपको पहले ही बताया ए
मैप से हम क्या करेंगे क्याक करेंगे
एन्यूमरेशन करेंगे हम डिस्कवर करेंगे लाइव
होस्ट को रिवर्स डीएनएस लुक अप करेंगे
टारगेट को स्कैन करेंगे डिटेक्ट करेंगे
वर्जन वगैरह ये सब करेंगे ठीक है तो सबसे
पहला जो पार्ट आता है वो आता है
डिस्कवरी ऑफ लाइव होस्ट अब यह हम काम
क्यों करेंगे मैं आपको बता देता हूं मान
लो हमारे पास एक टारगेट है एक टारगेट
टारगेट क्या है xyz.com ये टारगेट अब मान
लो ये टारगेट डाउन है डाउन है अप नहीं है
डाउन है तो इस पे बाकी फर्द हम वर्जन
डिटेक्शन वगैरह करने का क्या फायदा क्यों
करेंगे हमारा टाइम वेस्ट हो जाएगा हमारा
टारगेट हमेशा अप होना चाहिए अप तभी तो हम
आगे प्रोसेस करेंगे तभी तो कोई फायदा है
अगर अप नहीं है डाउन है फिर क्या फायदा
आगे के स्टेप्स के टाइम वेस्ट है तो हम
टारगेट को चेक करने के लिए कि टारगेट अप
है है कि डाउन है हम बेसिकली डिस्कवरी
करते हैं या होस्ट डिस्कवरी भी आप इसको
बोल सकते हो होस्ट डिस्कवरी करते हैं
सिंपल अब भाई होस्ट डिस्कवरी करने के भी
अलग-अलग तरीके हैं किन-किन तरीकों से आप
कर सकते हैं एक पहला
तरीका अगर आपको होस्ट डिस्कवरी करना है तो
एक पहला तरीका ए आरपी के थ्रू आप कर सकते
हैं ए आरपी रि पैकेट भेज के आप कर सकते
हैं दूसरा तरीका आप टीसीपी पैकेट्स भेज के
कर सकते हैं तीसरा तरीका आप यूडीपी
पैकेट्स भेज के कर सकते हैं चौथा तरीका आप
आईसीएमपी पैकेट्स भेज के कर सकते
हैं सॉरी ये तरीके से आप होस्ट डिस्कवरी
कर सकते हैं अब अगर मुझे एकदम से नॉर्मली
बताना होता ना जैसे कि फ्री कोर्स है अरे
यार बच्चों को कुछ भी बता दो मतलब फ्री
कोर्स है उसके हिसाब से बता दो तो मैं मैं
पता है क्या
करता आपको बिलीव नहीं होगा आपको बिलीव
नहीं होगा मतलब मैं पता है मैं क्या करता
मैं बताइए आप मुझे चैट मैं सबका चैट में
देख रहा हूं ठीक है आ आई एम सीइंग एवरीवन
चैट बीच-बीच में मैं देखता हूं तो आपको
ज्यादा टेंशन लेने की जरूरत नहीं है ठीक
है पता है मैं क्या करता अगर मैं
डायरेक्टली अगर फ्री वाला सिस्टम पर चलाता
तो मैं मैं सिंपल क्या करता मैं आपको काली
लिनिक्स इस तरीके से ओपन कर देता मैं
सोचता कि अरे यार फ्री कोर्स है
ना मैं क्या करता इस तरीके से टर्मिनल ओपन
कर देता काली में मैं बोलता कि एक एन मैप
है ठीक है एक हाइन पी आर कमांड चलाते हैं
पीआर किसलिए हमारे पास एक एन मैप की चीट
शीट है भैया चलिए मैं चीट शीट को ओपन कर
लेता
हूं यह चीट शीट है इसमें आपको दिखेगा पीआर
हाई फन पीआर ए आरपी डिस्कवरी ऑन लोकल
नेटवर्क तो मैं क्या करता कि इसी तरीके से
पीआर लगा देता यहां पर उसके बाद न sn1
क्यों होता है यह भी दिखा देता हूं देख
लीजिए यहां पे यह चीटशीट में आपको पता चल
जाएगा n
map-reduce ये मेरे नेटवर्क को स्कैन
करेगा ए आरपी के थ्रू एआर पी रिक्वेस्ट
सेंड करके और मुझे जो भी रिजल्ट्स है वो
मुझे लाकर देगा बेसिकली क्या कर रहा है ये
होस्ट डिस्कवरी कर रहा है मैं यहां पे
यहां पे आई थिंक ऐड आ गई है तो आप थोड़ा
ऐड को स्किप कर लीजिएगा ठीक है सिंपल हम
यही काम करते या मैं यही काम करता और आपको
यहां पर रिजल्ट देखने को मिल जाता कि
देखिए यह होस्ट अप है कौन सा ये मैक
एड्रेस जो है एंड आईपी एड्रेस ये रहा तो
आप 29.1 फिर 29.4 29.1 29.4 ये ल ये मेरी
ये
अ स्टूडेंट्स को पागल बना रहे हैं बहुत
तरीकों से मैं नाम नहीं लूंगा किसी का भी
आई एम नॉट टेकिंग नेम आई एम नॉट हैविंग
एनी ग्रज टुवर्ड्स एनी वन बट जब कोई किसी
को जब कोई टीचर हो या ट्रेनर हो या कंटेंट
क्रिएटर हो जब सामने स्टूडेंट्स को पागल
बनाते हैं नॉलेज के नाम पे कोर्सेस के नाम
पे उनके कोर्स जो होते हैं जिसमें
क्वालिटी नहीं होती है कोर्स में पाच 5000
के कोर्स है 101 हज के हैं भाई इवन चलो
2000 का भी है उसमें क्वालिटी नहीं मिलती
है तो मुझे फिर उस टाइम बहुत गुस्सा आता
है वैसे लोगों पे चाहे वह हमारी सेम
कम्युनिटी के हो या बाहर के हो कोई भी
उससे फर्क नहीं पड़ता है तो आपको यहां पे
क्वालिटी कंटेंट मिल रही है आपका साथ
मिलेगा आप बस ध्यान से अपने डेडिकेशन से
आप कंटिन्यू कीजिए इस पूरी सीरीज को एंड
आपको इतना कुछ जानने को मिलेगा इतना कुछ
सीखने को मिलेगा ना जिसकी आपने कल्पना
नहीं की होगी आपने कोई इमेजिनेशन भी नहीं
किया होगा कि आपको फ्री में कोई इस तरह का
क्वालिटी कंटेंट भी देगा और वो आपको बात
गलत लगने लगेगी कि फ्री में सब कुछ नहीं
मिलता है सब मिल रहा है आपको याद
रखिएगा ठीक
है या
राइट राइट फिलहाल मैं अभी इस पे कंटिन्यू
करता हूं यहां पे मैं अभी इस पे नहीं आ
रहा फिलहाल के लिए ठीक है मैं फिलहाल के
लिए वापस से फिर चले जा रहा हूं जहां पे
हम करा रहे थे तो यहां पे ये तरीकों से आप
होस्ट डिस्कवरी कर सकते हैं
ए आरपी अब मैंने आपको वापस से बोला मैंने
आपको अगेन बोला है अगर आपको ए आरपी टीसीपी
यूडीपी एससी आईसीएमपी नहीं पता क्या होता
है आप प्लीज प्लेलिस्ट में जाइए हमारे
चैनल पे नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी की प्लेलिस्ट
पे आ जाइए और इसमें सारी आपको ये टॉपिक्स
हैं डिटेल में मिल जाएंगे इसलिए मैं बहुत
रिपीट नहीं ये सेम चीज रिपीट करने का कोई
फायदा नहीं है कि जो ऑलरेडी नेटवर्क
सिक्योरिटी में क्लास हो चुकी है मैं वापस
से वो क्लासेस लूं राइट तो आपको पता है
वेल एंड गुड अदर वाइज एक बार जस्ट एक बार
रिवाइज कर लीजिएगा ए आरपी पैकेट्स हम
भेजते हैं ए आरपी पैकेट्स भेज के एंड हम
यह देखते हैं कि सामने से मुझे कुछ
रिस्पांस आ रहा है कि नहीं रिस्पांस आ रहा
है मतलब वह पर्टिकुलर होस्ट लाइव है होस्ट
अप है चल रहा है काम कर रहा है चलिए अब
इसका एक जैसे मेरे पास एक एन मैप की
चीटशीट है यह चीटशीट गाइस मैंने आप लोगों
को भी प्रोवाइड कर दिया है अगर आपको लग
रहा है कि मैंने प्रोवाइड नहीं किया है
मैं झूठ बोल रहा हूं तो मैं आपको
सीधा-सीधा यहां पे सिंपल सा फंडा यहां पे
मैं आपको दिखाना चाहूंगा कि ये चीजें
प्रोवाइड हो चुकी है ऑलरेडी तो मैं अपने
फोन पे आपको दिखा देता हूं पहले फटाक
से चलिए तो यहां पे आप जब बेसिकली नक्स
एडमी ए एप पे जाएंगे यहां पे ए एप पे आ
जाइएगा यहां पे इस तरीके से तो यह बेसिकली
कौन सा यह कौन सा है यार यह तो मेरा मेन
ऐप है लग रहा है मुझे लग रहा है ठीक है यह
मेन ऐप है स्टोर पे मैं यहां पर देखता हूं
ये फ्री कोर्स वाला जो सेक्शन है इस पर जब
आप आइएगा कंटेंट में जाइएगा तो बग बाउंट
रिसोर्सेस में आप आएंगे तो आपको यहां पे
मैंने एन मैप का चीट शीट ऑलरेडी दिया हुआ
है यह रहा ये ए मैप का चीटशीट यहां पे
आपको यह मिल रहा है ये देखिए इसको आप
डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं एंड इसी में आपको यह
चीटशीट जो है जो मैं यूज कर रहा हूं
बेसिकली मिल जाएगी ठीक है चलिए धन्यवाद बस
इतना दिखाना था डेनिक्स एडमी ए एप
है अब यहां पे मुझे ए आरपी रिक्वेस्ट ए
आरपी अ का यूज करना है अब मैं कैसे करूंगा
वो मैं आपको दिखाता हूं देखिए जब चीटशीट
को ओपन कीजिएगा होस्ट डिस्कवरी के अंदर
में तो यहां पे एक हान पीआर स्विच है
स्विच का मतलब ऑप्शन जो ए मैप के साथ आप
यूज करते हैं
दैट्ची नहीं लगाएंगे ना हान ए तो क्या
होगा कि यह बार-बार पोर्ट स्कैन भी करेगा
तो हमें अभी नहीं करनी ना भाई
दैट्ची कर रहे हो
तुम मत करो यार इतने हाई मतलब ये डीजे
बहुत पैसे वाला लगता है मुझे चलो ठीक है
एनीवे थैंक यू एंड प्लीज कंटिन्यू द सेशन
प्लीज तो यहां पे हान ए लगाइए तो डिसेबल
पोर्ट स्कैनिंग पोर्ट स्कैनिंग को डिसेबल
कर देता है हमने सेम काम यहां पे अपने
मशीन पे किया है हमने अपने काली मशीन पे
किया है एंड हमने क्या किया है ए मैप
कमांड चलाया है न प किया है न
sn2 168
29.12 इसका मतलब जितने भी होस्ट है 250 56
होस्ट जो आपके इस नेटवर्क में है लोकल
एरिया नेटवर्क में वह सारे इसमें इंक्लूड
हो जाते हैं आप सिंगल सिंगल भी कर सकते हो
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक
है ओके अब यहां पे मैं क्या करूंगा मैं
यहां पे एंटर मारूंगा ओके मैं यहां पे
एंटर मारूंगा मैं यहां पे यहां पे ऐड चल
रहा है तो यहां पे ऐड को मैंने बंद कर
दिया मैं यहां पे एंटर करूंगा एंटर जैसे
ही करूंगा ये अपना काम स्टार्ट करेगा एंड
ये बेसिकली रिक्वेस्ट कर रहा है ए आरपी
रिक्वेस्ट अब ये क्या है एआर पी रिक्वेस्ट
भाई क्यों जरूरी है अब इसका इसमें हो क्या
रहा है अब देखिए यहां पे ये तो सिंपल सा
रिक्वेस्ट आ गया यहां पे यहां पे
रिक्वेस्ट का रिप्लाई आ गया कि होस्ट इज
अप एक हमारा होस्ट है ये हमारा
reliance.in जो कि हमारा क्या है राउटर है
उसके बाद जो होस्ट है अ
यह 19 29.4 यह एक होस्ट है उसके बाद एक
अननोन होस्ट यह है
[संगीत]
भी बताता है बेसिकली ठीक है तो अब यहां पे
जब आप आएंगे यहां पे तो यहां पे देखिए आप
यहां पे देखिए जब मैंने रीजन ये फ्लैग
लगाया तो अब मुझे क्या आ रहा है होस्ट इज
अब रिसीवड ए आरपी रिस्पांस रिसीवड ए आरपी
रिस्पांस रिसीवड ए आरपी रिस्पांस मतलब
इनको क्या मिल रहा है ए आरपी रिस्पांस मिल
रहा है जब आप रीजन करके देखेंगे तो आपको ए
आरपी या फिर आप रीजन तो लगा दिए साथ में
हाइन v लगा दो या वीवी लगा दो वर्वस मोड
के लिए तो आप ये वाला कमांड भी चला सकते
हो फवीवी तो अब जो आपको रिजल्ट्स आएंगे
देखते
जाइए जस्ट
वेट चलो
अब यहां पे जब मैंने हाइन वीवी लगाया तो
अब देखिए कितना डिटेल में आपको रिजल्ट मिल
रहा है लेट्स सी स्टार्टिंग एंड मैप बहुत
बढ़िया स्कैनिंग 255 होस्ट क्योंकि हमने
सीआईडीआर नोटेशन यूज किया है स् 24 वाला
तो यहां पे 255 होस्ट सारे एक वन पोर्ट पर
होस्ट यानी कि ये कितने पोर्ट को स्कैन कर
रहा है एक पोर्ट पर होस्ट यह स्कैनिंग कर
रहा है क्योंकि हमने यहां पे बेसिकली अभी
कोई भी पोर्ट नंबर या पोर्ट स्कैनिंग
असाइन नहीं किया है तो यह कर ही नहीं रहा
है बेसिकली क्या कर रहा है सिंपल सा होस्ट
डिस्कवरी कर रहा है इसलिए ये वन पोट पर
होस्ट यहां पे लिखा हुआ है अब देखिए नीचे
आ
जाइए नीचे आएंगे तो इसने पहले सबसे पहला
आईपी 19216 29.0 इसको को स्कैन किया एंड
यहां पे आ रहा है होस्ट डाउन रिसीवड नो
रिस्पांस उसके बाद 1921 29.1 ये राउटर है
हमारा रिसीवड ए आरपी रिस्पांस तो क्या है
ये होस्ट अप है वैसे ही होस्ट डाउन रिसीवड
नो रिस्पांस होस्ट डाउन रिसीवड नो
रिस्पांस यहां पे समझ में आ रहा पहले इधर
ध्यान दे लीजिए सभी लोग प्लीज प्लीज
टारगेट आईपी कहां से मिलेगा अरे यार
टारगेट आईपी कहां से मिलेगा भाई बताओ इनको
कल की कल लास्ट वाली क्लास 15 नहीं देखी
थी क्या इसलिए मैं बोलता हूं हर एक क्लास
देखा करो उसी में मैंने यही तो बताया था
टारगेट आईपी कहां से लेनी है मास स्कैन
नाबू रस्ट स्कैन यूज किया था तो उस टारगेट
आईपी के लिए तो किया था कि हमें व टारगेट
एक आईपी का रेंज मिल गया एक आईपी की डी
पूरी लिस्ट मिल जाए या आईपी एड्रेसस मिल
जाए
दैट्ची नो रिस्पांस ये देखिए ये सब दिख
रहा है आपको यहां पे होस्ट डाउन जैसे ही
होस्ट को कोई रिसीव रिस्पांस रिसीव हुआ है
होस्ट इज अप सिंपल एंड यहां पे कौन सा
रिस्पांस है ए आरपी रिस्पांस है क्यों
क्योंकि हमने यहां पे हाइन पीआर ऑप्शन यूज
किया है जब आपको बाकी लोग बताएंगे तो बस
पीआर ऑप्शन बता देते हैं एआर पीए स्कैन है
क्यों क्यों कैसे इसका जवाब तो आना चाहिए
ना यह रहा आपके सामने सारी जवाब है आपके
जो भी क्वेश्चन है उसका जवाब है य तो ये ए
आरपी स्कैनिंग इस तरीके से आपने क्या किया
आपने ए आरपी स्कैनिंग की आपने ए आरपी
रिक्वेस्ट भेजा और उसको रिस्पांस के तौर
पे यहां पे आपके सामने आ गया अब मुझे इसी
पे अब देखो देखो क्या होता क्या है अब
मुझे मान लो सेम चीज है मुझे इस पे कोई
पोर्ट को स्कैन करना है लेट्स सपोज कोई
पोर्ट ही स्कैन करना है तो मैं यहां पे
पोर्ट वाला ऑप्शन हा फन प एंड मान लो कोई
पोर्ट जैसे कोई सी भी पोर्ट लगा दो हमको
स्कैन करना है वो पोर्ट यहां पे लगा सकते
हो जैसे मान लो 80 पोर्ट के लिए करना है
80 लगा दिया या हान प 80 ऐसे कर कर दो आप
तो ये स्पेसिफिक पोर्ट के लिए कर सकता है
अब देखो यहां पे जैसे मैंने न प किया अब
यहां पे क्यों आ रहा है यू कैन नॉट यूज
हान f और हाइन p व्हेन नॉट डूइंग अ पोर्ट
स्कैन ऐसा क्यों लिखा
भाई क्यों लिखा अरे डीजे
यार चलो यहां पे मैं आता हूं उस पे यहां
पे क्यों लिखा क्योंकि आप हान s ए यूज कर
रहे हैं तो आप हान प8 नहीं यूज कर सकते
ऐसा क्यों भैया ऐसा इसलिए ब बज यहां पर
हाइन एसन का मतलब है डिसेबल पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग बंद कर दो तो नहीं होगा ना तो
हमें हाइफ एसन यहां पर कमांड से हटाना
पड़ेगा चलिए एक बार हटा के देख लेते हैं
हाइन एस
को टिक टिक टिक टिक टिक टिक एंड देन एंटर
करते हैं स्टार्ट हो गया भाई हान प8 यह
देखिए यहां पे डन अब इसने क्या किया भैया
इसने एक तो होस्ट डिस्कवरी कर ली पहले तो
क्यों होस्ट डिस्कवरी कर ली क्योंकि हमने
होस्ट डिस्कवरी चलाई हुई थी भाई हाइन पीआर
लगा के ए आरपी डिस्कवरी की थी होस
डिस्कवरी तो इसने सारे होस्ट डिस्कवरी कर
लिए होस डाउन डाउन डाउन डाउन डाउन डाउन
डाउन जो अप है वो उसका अप दिखाएगा यार
डाउन डाउन डाउन डाउन यह रहा यह सब अब यहां
पर नीचे आके यह पोर्ट्स को स्कैन कर रहा
है यह देखिए 80 पोर्ट इस मैक एड्रेस पे
फिर से ये स्कैनिंग यह स्कैनिंग यह देख
रहे हैं ये स्कैनिंग ये स्कैनिंग ये सारे
स्कैनिंग करके रिजल्ट आपको प्रोवाइड कर
रहा है ट्स इट तो इस तरह से आपने क्या
किया आपने स्कैनिंग भी कर ली
चलिए ओके ये डीजे डीजे फिर से देखो फिर से
000 का सुपर चैट किया है डीजे ने डीजे
रहने दो अब बहुत हो गया ठीक है धन्यवाद
थैंक यू सर एक बार देख लेते हैं सर जो
मर्जी बोलिए बट जो नॉलेज आप फ्री में
प्रोवाइड कर रहे हो ऐसा कोई नहीं करता इसे
आप अपने सभी सब्सक्राइबर की तरफ से एक
छोटी सी गुरु दक्षिणा
समझिए चलो
बहुत बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद डीजे
एंड क्या बोलू मैं हा चलो अगर ऐसी
माइंडसेट है आज भी ऐसे स्टूडेंट्स की तो
दैट इज वह आप बहुत बड़ी बात होती है आज के
टाइम में चलो ठीक है गाइस
तो यहां पर आपने यह ए आरपी स्कैन समझ लिया
अब अब ए आरपी स्कैन को विजुलाइज करना
चाहते हो क्या देखना चाहते हो आंखों से ए
आरपी स् हो कैसे रहा है ऐसे ऐसे ऐसे ऐसे
कैसे हो रहा है सब लोग देखना चाहते हैं तब
बताइए मुझे देन आई विल लेट यू
नो बताइए
मुझे आप लोगों को विजुलाइज करना है सभी
लोग बोलेंगे तभी मैं कराऊंगा विजुलाइज
क्योंकि भाई थोड़ा सा रिस्पांस तो चाहिए
यार आपको देखना है ए आरपी रिस्पांस ए आरपी
रिक्वेस्ट रिस्पांस काम कैसे कर रही है
एक्चुअल में कैसे वो आप देख सकते हो उसको
यू कैन सी विथ योर आइज
पैकेट कैसे जा रहा है डू ऐसे
ड एक दोती च पा 6 सा 8 9 10 लोगों का ओनली
रिप्लाई आया और यहां पर है 44 लोग यह तो
नाइंसाफी है भाई यार रिप्लाई तो करना
पड़ेगा मैं सोने नहीं मैं सोने नहीं दूंगा
भाई बग
बाउंटीज नहीं करोगे तो यह तो नहीं चलेगा
भाई रिप्लाई तो करना पड़ेगा ओके
ठीक
है
ग्रेट बहुत बढ़िया चलो यह हुई ना बात चलिए
अब मैं आपको दिखाता हूं हम क्या करेंगे
सेम कमांड चलाएंगे
ए आरपी वाली एकदम सिंपल सा यहां
पर यह कमांड सिर्फ होस डिस्कवरी का बट
इसको चलाने से
पहले हम क्या करेंगे हम एक और टूल का यूज
करने वाले हैं जो अपने आप में ब बहुत ही
खतरनाक टूल है बहुत खतरनाक टूल है जिसके
बारे में आप सबने सुना होगा एंड ट टूल इज
नोन एज वायर
शार्क वायर शार्क देखते जाओ अभी क्या क्या
सीखने वाले हो तुम लोग अभी तो बहुत कुछ
है ठीक है धन्यवाद
चलिए ओके ग्रेट रबिन वायर शार्क जो है यह
एक
पैकेट एनालाइजर टूल
है ठीक है यूज्ड बाय यूज्ड बाय
इंडिविजुअल्स
हैकर्स
कंपनीज या कॉरपोरेट बोल लो व्हाट एवर यू
वांट टू से हर कोई यूज करता है ठीक है अब
हम जो हम कर रहे हैं ना सामने जो हमने थरी
में पढ़ा उसको प्रैक्टिकली
देखेंगे ठीक है प्रैक्टिकली इसके लिए हमें
चलाना है काली में आपके वाय शर्क इनबिल्ट
आता है तो हम इसको चलाएंगे वाय शर्क को
वाय शर्क सर्च कीजिएगा वाय शर्क ओपन हो
जाएगा इस तरीके से कुछ इंटरफेस यहां पर
आपको नीचे देखने को मिलेंगे इंटरफेस का
नाम अब इसमें आपका कौन सा इंटरफेस है वह
चूज करना है आपको मेरा क्या है ईटीच जीरो
है अब मुझे कैसे पता टीए जीरो है मैं आपको
दिखा देता हूं कमांड टर्मिनल ओपन कीजिए
यहां टाइप कीजिए आईएफ
कॉन्फिन कर
दीजिए जब आप एंटर कर देंगे तो आपको यहां
पे नेटवर्क इंटरफेस का नाम आ जाएगा एक टी0
यूज हो रहा है एक लूप बैक जो है आपका वो
यूज हो रहा है तो ओबवियसली वी आर यूजिंग
टीए 0 जहां पे हमें एक ये वाली आईपी एक
ब्रिज वाली एक लोकल आईपी मिल चुकी है ठीक
है चलिए तो हम यहां पे टीए जीरो को चूज कर
लेंगे डबल क्लिक कर देते हैं अब ये क्या
करेगा ईटीच जीरो पे यानी हमारे एडॉप्टर पे
जो भी चीजें हो रही हैं जो भी पैकेट्स अप
डाउन सेंड रिसीव हो रहा है वो ये कैप्चर
करेगा ठीक है ये क्या करेगा कैप्चर करेगा
तो मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
यहां पर यह कमांड चलाता हूं एंड वेट करता
हूं चलिए मैं यहां पर कमांड यहां पर चलाया
और आई एम वेटिंग एंड लेट्स ओपन वायर शार्क
और यह देखिए वायर शार्क में आपको यहां पर
कुछ चीजें दिख रही होंगी
देखिए यह देखिए बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है
यह देखिए एक रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है यहां पर
यह रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है बहुत सारी
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है
देखिए यह देखिए यहां पर ये बहुत सारी
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है ठीक है अब ये
रिक्वेस्ट क्या है हम इस पे भी आएंगे बहुत
जल्द आएंगे और आपको मैं लाइव दिखाऊंगा
चलिए यहां पे देखा यह रिक्वेस्ट गई यहां
पे हमें रिजल्ट आके मिल चुका है यहां पे
रिजल्ट तो हमें मिल चुका बट वाय शार्प में
हमने जो रिक्वेस्ट भेजा यानी कि हमने यानी
किसने हमने यानी किसने इस वीएम वेयर की
मशीन काली ने किस आईपी ने इस आईपी
ने ये रिक्वेस्ट भेजा ठीक है अब हमने जब
रिक्वेस्ट भेजा तो यह रिक्वेस्ट यहां पे
कैप्चर हुआ वायर
शार्क ठीक है कैप्चर हो गया अब क्या
कैप्चर हुआ भाई यह भी तो देखना है कि
कैप्चर क्या हुआ तो चलिए देखते हैं कि
कैप्चर क्या हुआ हमने जब रिक्वेस्ट भेजना
शुरू
किया हमने जब रिक्वेस्ट भेजना शुरू किया
तो यहां पर ए आरपी पैकेट जा रही है जिस
जिस इस वाले लाइन को देखिए ध्यान से ए
आरपी पैकेट जा
यह देखिए प्रोटोकॉल ए आरपी सोर्स क्या है
व एमवेयर
34 यह क्या है भाई
34 यह किसी को आईडिया है
34 क्या है चलिए हम अपने इस पर आते हैं
एंड यहां पर आपको जब मैं मैक एड्रेस
दिखाऊंगा हमारे इस मशीन की तो आपको मैक
एड्रेस दिख जाएगा मैक एड्रेस में आपको
स्टार्टिंग के थ्री जो फील्ड होते हैं
आपको पता होगा कि यह बताते हैं कि
मैन्युफैक्चरर कौन है इस पर्टिकुलर मैक
एड्रेस को असाइन करने वाला प्रोवाइडर कौन
है ओईए कौन है ओरिजिनल इक्विपमेंट
मैन्युफैक्चरर जिसको बोलते हैं एंड लास्ट
थ्री वाला एक्चुअल में अभी के लिए बस इतना
समझिए कि वो एक आईडी आपको दे देता है
यूनिक आईडी एक है वो आपको ये दे देता है
तो यह आईडी जो है यही आईडी यहां रिफ्लेक्ट
होती है पहला वाला तो आपका नाम रिफ्लेक्ट
हो गया वीएम वेयर कॉरपोरेशन की तरफ से और
लास्ट थ्री जो आपके जो फील्ड्स है 3a ओ 04
मैक एड्रेस का वो यहां प आपको दिख रहा है
राइट यस वेंडर कौन है ओईए कौन है यहां पर
आपको दिख रहा है अब जब यह रिक्वेस्ट यह
ब्रॉडकास्ट लिखा हुआ है क्यों क्योंकि
यहां से यहां पर क्या हो रहा है पैकेट
वीएम वेर से जाके वीएम वेर को जा रहा है
मतलब यह खुद एक ब्रॉडकास्ट सर्वर की तरह
काम कर रहा
है ठीक है अब यहां पर ए आरपी पैकेट भेजा
ओके लेंथ इसकी 42 है यहां पे एंड यहां पे
इंफो में देखिए ये क्या पूछ रहा है हु है
192168 29.1 किसके पास है यह
आईपी टेल 1921
29135 यह किससे पूछ रहा है यह खुद पूछ रहा
है यही पूछ यह पूछ रहा है आईपी से यह वाली
आईपी जो है यह वाली आईपी पूछ रहा है क्या
पूछ रहा है हमारी यह वाली आईपी कि हु हैज
दिस आईपी
29.1 बताइए किसके पास है क्योंकि ए आरपी
जो होता है एड्रेस रेजोल्यूशन प्रोटोकॉल व
क्या करता है जब ए आरपी रिक्वेस्ट
ब्रॉडकास्ट होती है तो वह आपके लोकल एरिया
नेटवर्क में जितने भी डिवाइस है सबके पास
जाता है उसके पास आईपी एड्रेस होती
है उसके पास क्या होती है आईपी एड्रेस
होती है लोकल एरिया जो भी आपके नेटवर्क
में डिवाइस वो उन आईपी एड्रेसस को जाकर
बोलता है कि भैया ओ भैया आपका मैक एड्रेस
क्या है ओ भ आपका मैक एड्रेस क्या है यह
पूछता है सारे आईपी एड्रेस और वही जो मैक
एड्रेस रिटर्न कर देता है वह समझता है यह
होस्ट लाइव है एंड इसी का यूज एन मैप करता
है एन मैप फिर हमें बताता है कि होस्ट जो
है हमारा भैया ये अप है तो जिन जिन होस्ट
के पास यह गया है अप है यानी इन होस्ट्स
ने ए आरपी रिप्लाई किया है और अपना मैक
एड्रेस बताया है इसको ए मैप
को समझ में आया बहुत ही सिंपल है इतना समझ
में अब देखो यहां पे ये कंकूट वली कर रहा
है पहले 29.1 हमारी आईपी को फिर 29.2 को
29.3 को 456 सारे होस्ट को क्योंकि
हमने स्लैश किया था थैंक यू अक्षत स् 24
सीआईडी नोटेशन सबनेटिंग आपको अगर पता होगा
या पढ़ लीजिए या नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी की
क्लास कर लीजिएगा आपको सबनेटिंग का भी
आईडिया हो जाएगा तो बेसिकली जब स् 24 जो
भी होस्ट होता है तो 255 255 25.0 हम उसको
कंसीडर करते हैं उसमें 250 256 होस्ट आते
हैं वही 16/1 होता है तो 255 25500 जिसमें
कि प्रॉक्स आपको
65535 जो भी जितने भी आपके सर्विसेस है वो
सारी आ जाती है ठीक है तो यहां पे ये
एक-एक से पूछ रहा है अब मैं आपको इसका एक
और चीज दिखाता हूं देखिए यहां पे एक और
इंटरेस्टिंग है देखो देखो जब देख के फील
करोगे ना तुम जब तुम साइबर सिक्योरिटी को
जो भी चीज हो रही है उसको जब तुम फील करने
लगोगे ना वो भाई तुम्हें मजा आ जाएगा
तुम्हें सच में मजा आ जाएगा ठीक
है ओके जस्ट वेट जस्ट
वेट ओके क्या बोल रहे हो भाई
अ अरे डायग्राम मतलब ये सामने दिख रहा है
इसमें क्या डायग्राम बनाऊ भाई जो सामने
पैकेट्स दिख रहे हैं भाई इससे ज्यादा
डायग्राम क्या है ये सामने देखो सामने ठीक
है एकदम क्लियर है क्लियर है क्या क्लियर
है चलो ये क्या क्लियर है सिंपल सा क्लियर
क्या है डायग्राम बोल रहे हैं भाई तो
डायग्राम से भी इसमें प्लस नहीं होता क्या
बोर्ड वन अच्छा बोर्ड टू भी
क्या अच्छा फ्री में बोर्ड वन ही आता है
शायद ट में आई थिंक नहीं हो पाएगा तो इसको
मैं डिलीट कर देता हूं कोई बात
नहीं यह हमारा काली है वीएम में ठीक है यह
हमारी मान लो डिवाइसेसपोर्ट
ठीक है आईपी लेकर
192.16
8292 यह
192.168 29.3
192.16
1689 सॉरी राइटिंग के लिए इग्नोर मारिए यह
पूछेगा कि मैक एड्रेस बताओ अपना भाई मैक
एड्रेस बताओ भाई
अपना आपका मैक एड्रेस क्या है बताओ जो
इनको रिटर्न करेगा मैक एड्रेस समझेगा
होस्ट अप है अदर वाइज डाउन है सिंपल सा
फंडा है यही प ए आरपी डिस्कवरी में हम यूज
हम यही देख रहे हैं सिंपल सा फंडा ठीक
है अब देखिए यहां प यहां पे आपको दिख रहा
होगा क्योंकि यह एक रिक्वेस्ट है ए आरपी
रिक्वेस्ट है इस पर्टिकुलर मान लो इस पर
गई है मान लो 29.8 प तो इसको जब आप
एक्सपेंड कीजिएगा ए आरपी रिक्वेस्ट वाले
सेक्शन को तो यहां पर आपको दिख रहा होगा
कि एक रिक्वेस्ट है जिसमें कि देखिए यहां
प देखिए सेंडर मैक एड्रेस ये सेंडर मैक
एड्रेस वीएम वेर जो हमारा काली मशीन है
सेंडर आईपी एड्रेस जो हमारी काली की आईपी
है टारगेट मैक एड्रेस जो हमारा सामने वाला
मैक एड्रेस होगा क्योंकि ये रिटर्न नहीं
हुआ है कोई मैक एड्रेस क्योंकि इसने तो
रिप्लाई नहीं किया ना भाई इसने तो कोई
रिप्लाई नहीं किया इस पर्टिकुलर आईपी ने
कौन सा आईपी था ये अ 29.8 ये डिवाइस ने
रिप्लाई नहीं किया इसको तो यहां पे रो मैक
एड्रेस आ रहा है ठीक है एंड यहां पे यह
वाली ये टारगेट आईपी ये वाली जो आईपी है
अब अब यहां पर हम रिक्वेस्ट में जब इसको
फिल्टर जब हम यहां पर अब देखिए हम इस वाले
सेक्शन को इथरनेट वाले सेक्शन को जब
एक्सपेंड करेंगे तो यहां पे डेस्टिनेशन
आपको दिख जाएगा सोर्स आपको दिख जाएगा
बेसिकली एंड फ्रेम वाले को करेंगे तो यहां
पर बाकी डिटेल्स जो है आपको पैकेट से
रिलेटेड वो सारी मिल जाएगी ठीक है अब यहां
पे एक ऐसे पैकेट को देखते हैं चलिए देखते
हैं जो रिप्लाई किया
जिसने
चलिए ये रहा मिल गया हमारा पहला हमारा
पहला जो है ना
यह मिल गई यह हमारी जो टारगेट है पहली मिल
गई अब देखो इसमें क्या हुआ है सोर्स ठीक
है डेस्टिनेशन यहां पर आपका वीएम वेयर हो
चुका है क्यों भाई सारे में सोर्स में वी
एमवेयर आपका सोर्स है यहां डेस्टिनेशन
वीएम वेर क्यों हो गया मुझे बताइए
कोई बताइए हां हां हां हां ऐसी कोई आईपी
होगी नहीं ना
बताइए
एवरीवन
टेल सॉरी यहां पे सब में क्या है सोर्स
वीएम वेर क्योंकि हम एर पी रिक्वेस्ट ववे
से भेज रहे हैं यहां पर डेस्टिनेशन वीएम
वेर क्यों हो
चुका क्योंकि उसको मिल गया बिल्कुल
क्योंकि क्योंकि यह ए आरपी रिप्लाई है यह
ए आरपी रिक्वेस्ट था यह ए आरपी रिप्लाई है
और जब ए आरपी रिप्लाई होगा भाई तो खुद
सोचो ना जब ए आरपी रिप्लाई होगा तो यह
डिवाइस रिप्लाई करेगा ना हमारे काली मशीन
को तो यह हो जाएगा सोर्स उस टाइम पर
रिप्लाई के लिए और यह हमारा काली
डेस्टिनेशन हो
जाएगा समझ में आ रहा
है समझ में आ रहा है इतना तो क्लियर हो
गया होगा बहुत सिंपल सा है तो यहां पे एर
प रिप्लाई हो रहा है इसलिए अब यह रिप्लाई
कहां से आ रहा है सरकम यह क्या है मेरा
राउटर है दिस इज माय राउटर तो राउटर से
रिप्लाई आया वीएम वेर को ये देखिए यहां पे
ये देखिए यहां पे ए आर प रिप्लाई लिखा हुआ
रहा है ये देखिए ये ब्लू लेफ्ट नीचे में
एआर पी रिप्लाई तो अब ये रिप्लाई करता है
देखिए 192 168 29.1 इज एट दिस 58.9 5.8 ये
मेरे राउटर का मैक एड्रेस है इसने मैक
एड्रेस रिटर्न कर दिया यहां ए आरपी को जब
एक्सपेंड करेंगे तो आपको दिख रहा होगा
यहां पर कि सेंडर मैक एड्रेस अब ये मेरा
राउटर है सेंडर आईपी मेरा राउटर है
डेस्टिनेशन टारगेट मैक एड्रेस मेरा वीएम
वेर है और टारगेट आईपी मेरा काली है या वी
एमवेयर है गट
इट समझने में इजी हुआ
होगा अरे अक्षत क्या बोल रहे हो यार यार
मतलब कुछ कुछ भी बोल रहे हो तुम लोग ऐसे
ना बोला करो यार दिक्कत हो जाएगी फिर चलो
यह तो हमें समझ में आ गया तो यह हमने क्या
किया भैया हमने यहां पर एन मैप का यूज
करके टारगेट को स्कैन किया देखो एक बहुत
शानदार एक्सप्लोइट प्रैक्टिकल भी आपको मैं
बताऊंगा दिखाऊंगा जिसमें आप सर्विस को
एक्सप्लोइट कर रहे होंगे एप का यूज करके
थोड़ा वेट करना पड़ेगा उसके
लिए
सॉरी तो यह आपको समझ में आ गया होगा
राइट ओके चलिए अब यहां पर हम हमने यह देख
लिया कि ए आरपी से हमने क्या की डिस्कवरी
की ए आरपी के डिस्कवरी के बाद हमारा जो
नेक्स्ट डिस्कवरी है वह है
टीसीपी या
यूडीपी इनमें से कोई एक उसके भी पहले हम
आईसीएमपी को कवर करने वाले आईसीएम इंटरनेट
कंट्रोल मैसेज प्रोटोकॉल बेसिकली आईसीएमपी
का काम बेसिकली क्या होता है ना एरर
रिपोर्ट टिंग का होता है जैसे दो नेटवर्क
कनेक्टिविटी है मान लो यह काली और यह
डिवाइस के बीच में कनेक्टिविटी बन रही है
मान लो कोई कनेक्टिविटी बन रही है अब इनके
बीच में कोई एरर आ जाती है कोई भी एरर आती
है तो इसका रिपोर्टिंग आईसीएमपी प्रोटोकॉल
करता है आईसीएमपी भी प्रोटोकॉल है टीसीपी
भी प्रोटोकॉल है यूडीपी भी प्रोटोकॉल है
ठीक है यह सब प्रोटोकॉल्स है ए आरपी भी
प्रोटोकॉल है एसटीटीपी भी प्रोटोकॉल है
डीएनएस भी प्रोटोकॉल है डीएसीपी भी
प्रोटोकॉल है सब प्रोटोकॉल्स है तो ये
आईसीएमपी का काम होता है अब आईसीएमपी इसको
कैसे रिपोर्ट करता आईसीएमपी क्या करता
है आईसीएमपी होस्ट डिस्कवरी की हम बात कर
रहे
हैं आईसीएमपी क्या करता है इको रिक्वेस्ट
करता
है इको रिक्वेस्ट
सोर्स और अगर डेस्टिनेशन से इसको ई को
रिप्लाई मिल जाए तो यह
समझता है होस्ट अप
है ठीक है
आईसीएम गट इट बस यही काम करता है या और
इसी का एक बहुत ही अच्छा एग्जांपल है
हमारा पिंग पिंग कमांड जो है ना पिंग जो
आप करते हैं यहां पर जैसे मैं पिंग कर रहा
हूं तो पिंग जो करते हैं और आपको रिप्लाई
मिलता है इस तरीके से पिंग एक आईसीएमपी
प्रोटोकॉल ही है उसी पर वर्क करता है तो
यहां पे आईसीएमपी का यूज करके हम होस्ट
डिस्कवरी
करेंगे बट आईसीएमपी का होस्ट डिस्कवरी
ऑलवेज फीजिबल नहीं होता है बिकॉज वाई
मोस्ट ऑफ
द फायरवॉल्स
नाउ अ डेज नाउ अ डेज
ब्लॉक्स
आईसीएमपी आईसीएमपी को ब्लॉक कर देते हैं
आईसीएमपी पैकेट्स को क्या कर देते हैं यह
ब्लॉक कर देते हैं आजकल के बहुत सारे
फायरवॉल्स इस वजह से यह बहुत ज्यादा
फीजिबल नहीं होता है बट हमें क्योंकि
जानकारी लेनी है जाननी है कहीं क्वेश्चन
पूछ दे कहीं कोई सर्टिफिकेशन में क्वेश्चन
आ जाए कुछ हो जाए कैसे पता चलेगा
भाई ठीक है कैसे पता चलेगा तो हमें यह
जानना तो है
ही बस तो हमें आईसीएमपी का जब यूज करेंगे
तो अब देखिए
सॉरी तो यहां पर आपके कमांड में कमांड में
सिंपल सेम कमांड रहेगा इसमें बस यहां पी
आर की जगह पीई आप कर देंगे पी आर के जगह
पे
पी और आप एंटर करेंगे तो अब जो है मैं
यहां पर आ जाता हूं मैं इसको क्या कर देता
हूं यहां पे स्टॉप कर देता हूं फिलहाल के
लिए ठीक है जस्ट जस्ट स्टॉपिंग इट ओके एंड
आई एम गोइंग टू
अ रीस्टार्ट इट एंड यहां पे मैं इसको एंटर
करता हूं जैसे मैं एंटर करूंगा मैं यहां
पर चलता हूं वा शर्क में एंड लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग लेट्स सी
देखिए यह दिख रहा है आपको आईसीएमपी
आईसीएमपी यह दिख रहा आईसीएमपी यहां पे अब
यहां पे हमने हाइन प यूज किया यहां पे
हमने हाइन प यूज किया बट अब जब आप इसका
हाइन आफ रीजन करेंगे तब आपको थोड़ा ज्यादा
डिटेल में आपको समझ में आएगा कि एक्चुअली
हो क्या रहा है देखिए
मैं रीजन दिखाना चाह रहा हूं यहां पर यह
देखिए यहां पर जब हमने रीजन यहां पर किया
यहां पे चलिए ऊपर चलते हैं ऊपर चलते हैं
यहां पे यहां पे रीजन में यहां प रीजन
हमने किया अब हम यहां पे यहां पे वापस से
चलते हैं अब जब आप यहां पर देखेंगे तो
यहां पर आईसीएमपी का आपको प्रोटोकॉल देखने
को मिल रहा है एंड यहां पर आपको आईसीएमपी
के कुछ कनेक्शंस एंड पैकेट्स देखने को मिल
रहे हैं दैट वी आर सीइंग द पैकेट्स
ठीक है
सर आदर्श सर डीजे लाइव स्ट्रीम ऑफ होने के
बाद रिफंड मांगेगा यह फ्रॉड बहुत हो रहा
है अब यह तो मुझे नहीं पता बट मुझे जहां
तक पता है ही इज अ रियल गाय आई डोंट नो
एनीथिंग अबाउट दैट और अगर मतलब मेरे साथ
कैसे फ्रॉड करोगे यार ये ये भी तो सोचो
यार मेरे साथ ही अगर तुम फ्रॉड करने लगोगे
या फ्रॉड हो जाए तो फिर मेरा फिर क्या
फायदा मेरा पढ़ाने का वो भी साइबर
सिक्योरिटी है ना समझिए थोड़ा यार और मुझे
नहीं लगता ही इज लाइक दैट पर्सन तो ऐसा
होता होगा मे बी वहां प बट ही इज नॉट
डूइंग एनी फ्रॉड ठीक है तो आप बिंदास रहिए
टेंशन फ्री रहिए एंड एकदम मस्त रहिए ठीक
है बी पॉजिटिव आदर्श
कुमार तो यहां पर हमें यहां पर फिर से
आईसीएमपी के पैकेट जो है यहां पे देखने को
मिल जाएंगे तो हमने क्या किया आईसीएमपी
वाला काम किया ठीक है यहां पर आईसीएमपी
हमने डिस्कवरी की अब चलिए यहां पर आते हैं
आईसीएमपी के बाद यह उतना फीजिबल नहीं है
तो मोस्ट ऑफ द टाइम यू विल नॉट बी यूजिंग
दिस आईसीएमपी तो इसलिए मैं इस पर ज्यादा
टाइम नहीं दे रहा ओके समझ में आ गया चलिए
अब यहां पर आते हैं
हमारे
टीसीपी होस्ट डिस्कवरी
पे ठीक है टीसीपी होस्ट डिस्कवरी जब ए मैप
की चीटशीट को जब आप ओपन करोगे तो यहां पे
होस्ट डिस्कवरी में आपको यहां पे कुछ
फ्लैक्स दिख रहे हैं ये देखिए हाइन पी एस
हाइन पी ए टीसीपी सीन डिस्कवरी टीसीपी एसी
के डिस्कवरी अब जब टीसीपी सिन डिस्कवरी
होगी तो बेसिकली यहां पे टीसीपी सिन
पैकेट्स भेजे जाएंगे और सिन एसी के का वेट
किया जाएगा आपको पता है याद है ना थ्रीवे
हैंड शेक भाई कि नहीं भूल गए बताओ मुझे
आपको याद है कि भूल गए थ्री वे हैंड
शेक जो मेरे स्टूडेंट्स रहे होंगे कोर्स
वगैरह के उनको थ्रीवे हैंड शेक अच्छे से
याद होगा और आपने अगर पढ़ा है तो भी अच्छी
बात है इस थ्रीवे हैंड शेक में क्या होता
है क्लाइंट होता है यह सर्वर होता है
क्लाइंट एक सिन रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है सर्वर
जो है सिन एसी के रेस्प करता है क्लाइंट
फिर उसको एक्नॉलेज करता है एसी के से ठीक
है सिंपल अब यहां पे इस सिन टीसीपी सिन
डिस्कवरी में क्या होगा सिन पैकेट को भेजा
जाएगा और वेट किया जाएगा सिन एसीके के
रिप्लाई का जैसे ही अगर आ जाता है रिप्लाई
तो मतलब वो रीचे बल है होस्ट नहीं आता है
नॉट रिचेल
सिंपल एन मैप का काम खत्म सोचो ए मैप कैसे
काम कर रहा है एन मैप इसी पे तो काम कर
रहा है समझ में आ रहा है आपको इसी पे तो
काम कर रहा है भाई ए मैप सिंपल चलिए तो
चलिए इसको भी देखेंगे भाई इसको क्यों
छोड़ेंगे चलिए काली पे आ जाते हैं ये
हमारे इस पे आ जाते हैं एंड यहां पे हमने
इसको कंटिन्यू विदाउट सेविंग कर दिया एंड
यहां पर हम सबसे पहला फ्लैग जो यूज करने
वाले सेम कमांड में हम ज्यादा कुछ भी नहीं
करने वाले हैं यहां पर हाइन एस ए प के जगह
पर सॉरी हम यहां पर
प एंड यहां पर एस पी एस लगाने वाले क्यों
पीएस लगाने वाले हैं क्योंकि यहां
आपको दिख रहा होगा यह चीट शीट में यहां पर
पीएस टीसीपी डिस्कवरी ऑन पोर्ट एक्स आप
किसी पोर्ट पर भी कर सकते हो या नॉर्मल से
होस्ट डिस्कवरी भी कर सकते हो सिंपल तो
यहां पर हम नॉर्मल सा क्या कर रहे हैं
होस्ट डिस्कवरी कर रहे हैं हमने यहां पीएस
किया और एंटर किया जैसे ही एंटर करेंगे
हमें वेट करना है उसके बाद थोड़ा सा वेट
कीजिए थोड़ा सा वेट कीजिए लेट्स
सी देखते जाइए वेट कीजिए वेट
कीजिए जस्ट
वेट
डिड वी गेट द रिजल्ट यस वी गेट द रिजल्ट
यहां पे डीसी इज एसपी स्टूडेंट गुड ग्रेट
बहुत बढ़िया तो अब हमें यहां पे जैसे ही
हमने किया हाइन पीएस तो यह टीसीपी क्या
हुआ यह भैया यह टीसीपी
सिन रिक्वेस्ट गई सिन पैकेट गया और सिन
पैकेट जाके यहां पे हमें क्या मिला
रिजल्ट्स मिल गए यहां पे सिन पैकेट जाके
यहां पे हमें रिजल्ट्स प्रोवाइड किए जा
रहे हैं जैसे यहां पर कोई एकय रिप्लाई आया
मान लो यहां पर लेट्स सपोज एंड यहां पर आप
जब इसको हम क्या करते हैं
लेट्स एक्सपेंड
इट एक काम करता हूं इसको वापस से कंटिन्यू
करते हैं एंड लेट्स कंटिन्यू विदाउट
सेविंग एंड लेट्स
अ कैप्चर
फिल्टर जस्ट
वेट लेट्स मूव टू द सेम कमांड हान पीएस
हान ए पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करनी नहीं है तो हां
पर हान ए लगाना जरूरी
है जस्ट
वेट
ओके इट्स नॉट कैपचरिंग
करेंटली
आईपी फर यहां पर हमारी क्या आ रही है आर
पी इट्स नॉट कैपचरिंग कैप्चर कर नहीं रहा
है एक सेकंड लेटस क्लोज
इट
आरवी
गुड गुड लेट्स सी वापस से एक बार कर लेते
हैं कुछ होता है कभी कभी प्रॉब्लम हो जाती
है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है कोई इशू नहीं है
देखते जाइए यहां पे लेट्स ओके एंड स्टार्ट
करते हैं सेम कमांड एंड पीएस हाफ एन एंड
दैट्ची
एक पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट पर हम एक बार एक बार
डिफाइन कर देते हैं जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट एक
काम करते हैं हम यहां
पर ए मैप यह सेम सेम चीज करते हैं हम य प
सेम टारगेट प हम अपना सेम टारगेट रखते हैं
बट हम पर्टिकुलर अगर पोर्ट प जाना चाहे तो
हम पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट पर भी डाल सकते हैं
जैसे कोई भी पोर्ट पर आपको कोई चलाना हो
तो हान प लगा के आप चला सकते हैं ठीक है
तो एक बार मैं क्या काम करता हूं जस्ट
स्टॉप इट ए लेट्स डू वन
थिंग लेट्स हियर एंड यहां पर हाइन एस ए जो
है इसको हटा देना पड़ेगा क्योंकि हान ए हम
नहीं लगा सकते हैं देन हम हाइन प ए लगा
देंगे सॉरी हाइन यहां
पे प लगा देते हैं एंड
80 80 पोर्ट राइट या फिर हाइन प हाइन प
सारे पोर्ट्स के लिए लगा दे क्या सारे
पोर्ट्स के लिए लगा देते हान प हान प एंड
लेट्स प्रेस द एंटर की लेट्स स्टार्ट
द
वेट ओके लेटस
टीसीपी पोर्ट
80 पोर्ट 0 के लिए पोर्ट इ 80 लेटस सी नॉट
कैपचरिंग
ओके जस्ट वेट टीसीपी पोर्ट कैपचरिंग यहां
हां यहां होने लगी ओके ओके सो या वी गॉट
नाउ हियर एक्चुअली क्या है वो फिल्टर हम
नहीं कर पा रहे थे तो हो रही थी बट हमें
एक्चुअली नहीं मिल पा रहा था वो वहां
पे वी वर नॉट गेटिंग राइट सो यहां पे अभी
देखिए यहां पे ये आपको दिख रहा होगा यहां
पे बेसिकली यहां पे जब टीसीपी पोर्ट
कैपचरिंग हो गई है अब देखो यहां पे क्या
हुआ है हम यहां पे ये अभी भी ये चल रहा है
है ना यहां पे हमने सारे पोर्ट्स के लिए
किया है बेसिकली जितने भी पोर्ट्स है ना
सबके लिए स्कैन अभी भी कर ही रहा है अभी
भी कर रहा है यह यहां पे हमने एक बेसिकली
फिल्टर सेट किया है कि टीसीपी पट इ = ए
क्योंकि हम यहां पे सारे पोर्ट्स के लिए
कर रहे हैं बेसिकली हाइन प हान प टोटल बट
यहां पे 80 पोर्ट वाला फिल्टर कर रहे हैं
बस और कुछ भी नहीं तो यहां पे अ 80 वाले
पोर्ट के लिए जो हमें रिस्पांस मिला है वो
रिस्पांस यहां पे मिला है देखिए यहां पे
सोर्स आपका क्या है ओबवियसली जो आपका काली
है वो सोर्स आपका रहेगा ठीक है एंड यहां
पे अनोले जमेंट पैकेट रेस्ट एंड
एक्नॉलेजमेंट यहां पे आ चुकी है यहां पे
आरएसटीएम एक्नॉलेजमेंट यानी एक्नॉलेजमेंट
आपकी आई है यहां पे एंड यहां पे
एक्नॉलेजमेंट किससे आई है भैया ये आई है
29.4 से उसके बाद यहां पे देखते हैं 29.1
से आपका एक्नॉलेजमेंट एक आया हुआ है आपका
पैकेट यहां पे एंड उसके बाद यहां पे बाकी
जो पैकेट है ये सिन रिक्वेस्ट भेज तो रहा
है यहां पे ये देखिए सिन इसने भेजा सिन
किसको भेजा भैया 14 को भेजा रिप्लाई आया
वन को भेजा यहां पे 43 को भेजा 135 को
भेजा ये वही आईपीस हैं जो एक्चुअली अभी चल
रहे हैं काम कर रहे हैं ठीक है बस दैट स
इट अब यहां
पे पोर्ट इ इक्वल टू 80 एंड ऐसे करते
हैं
टू
65535 मान लो मैं एक कोई दूसरा पोर्ट यूज
कर लेता हूं जैसे मैं 22 पोर्ट के लिए
देखता हूं कोई है कि नहीं 20 22 पोर्ट के
लिए है क्या यस 22 पोर्ट के लिए भी है ओके
43 भेज रहा है 43 है
हमारा 14 है 14 है सोर्स हमारा एंड फोर है
फ 4 एंड 14 ओके ठीक है ये है तो इस तरीके
से आप चेक आउट कर सकते हैं फिल्टर ल्टर
लगा के जो भी आपको फिल्ट्रेशन लगानी है
फिल्टर लगाइए उस पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट के लिए
पर्टिकुलर या चीज जो सर्विस है उसके लिए
आप यहां प फिल्टर करके चेक आउट कर सकते
हैं जो आपकी रिक्वेस्ट है तो अब यहां पे
आपको दिख रहा होगा ट्रांसमिशन कंट्रोल
प्रोटोकॉल टीसीपी जो हमने भेजा अब देखो
यहां पे क्या हो रहा है अब देखो यहां पे
पे सोर्स पोर्ट 80 है यहां पे डेस्टिनेशन
पोर्ट जो भी है यहां पे आपको दिख रहा होगा
यहां पे अब यहां पे देखा सीक्वेंस नंबर
सिन पैकेट भेज रहा है सिन पैकेट सीक्वेंस
नंबर इसने क्या किया वन सिन वन सीक्वेंस
नंबर आ गया यहां पे वन गॉट इट अब यहां पे
आ जाइए नेक्स्ट रिक्वेस्ट नंबर यहां पे
उसके बाद यहां नीचे आ जाइएगा फ्लैग्स यहां
पे जो आ रहे हैं रेस्ट और आर एसटी और
एसीके का फ्लैग यहां पे आपको जो रिस्पांस
में मिल रहा है बेसिकली जिसकी हम बात कर
रहे हैं ठीक है आर एसटी एन एसी के तो ये
आपको मिल गया यहां पे क्योंकि यहां पे
सोर्स अब दूसरा एक डिवाइस है जो कि आपके
काली पे यहां पे रिस्पॉन्ड बैक कर रहा है
तो जब अगर रिस्पॉन्ड बैक कर रहा है अगर
वहां पर इसका मतलब है कि वो ओपन है एंड वो
पोर्ट आपका चलर उसपे कोई सर्विस है और ओपन
है आप उसको ओपन समझ सकते हो और ये आपको
रिजल्ट दे देगा कि भैया ओपन है ट्स इट तो
ये पोर्ट स्कैनिंग भी कर रहा है इसलिए
यहां पे इतना टाइम लगा रहा है अगर हमने
सिर्फ और सिर्फ होस्ट का स्कैन किया होता
ना जैसे ये किया हान पीएस के लगा दिया
हाइन
ए हान
एसन हाइन एसन डिसेबल पोर्ट स्कैनिंग अगर
हमने सिर्फ यह किया रहता और यहां पर अगर
हम फिर से लेट्स
सपोज मैं इसको रीस्टार्ट कर देता हूं एंड
देन आईम गोइंग टू एंटर ठीक
है यस हा आर एसटी रिसेट रिसेट बिल्कुल
यहां पे अब आप यहां पे आप करते जाइए अगर
आपको कुछ मिलता है तो बढ़िया बात है नहीं
मिलता है कोई बात नहीं यहां पे टीसीपी
पोर्ट यहां पे इसको मैं यहां पे रिमूव कर
देता हूं
टीसीपी टीसीपी एंड लेट्स रिमूव इट एंड
लेट्स सी तो इस तरीके से आपको यहां पे ये
पैकेट्स को आप इन पैकेट्स को क्या कर सकते
हैं बेसिकली रीड आउट कर सकते हैं तो आपको
वायर शर्क में रीड आउट करना पैकेट को अगर
आता है तो बहुत अच्छी बात है आप रीड करके
पैकेट्स को देख सकते हैं पैकेट्स कहां जा
रहे है थोड़ा बहुत अगर लाइक कभी-कभी आपको
नहीं दिख रहा है फिल्टर लगाइए फिल्टर में
आप पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट के लिए पर्टिकुलर
प्रोटोकॉल के लिए फिल्टर लगाइए एंड आपको
दिखना शुरू हो जाएगा तो ये तो मैंने आपको
एक ओवरव्यू दिया वायर शार्क के ऊपर में
अगर आपको चाहिए कि वायर शार्क के ऊपर भी
एक डिटेल ट्यूटोरियल लेकर आऊं मैं तो आप
बता दीजिएगा वो वीडियो फॉर्म में आ जाएगी
लाइव में शायद ना आए वीडियो फॉर्म में
आपके लिए मैं लेकर आ जाऊंगा टेंशन नहीं
लेनी है आपको वायर्क के ऊपर एक कंप्लीट
डिटेल वीडियो तो आपको वाय शार की पूरी
नॉलेज हो जाएगी क्या-क्या कैसे-कैसे करते
हैं किस तरीके से वो काम करता है सारी
चीजें ठीक है
आर एसटी फ्लैग देता है मतलब
एडप क्लोज करना फिनिश का मतलब बहुत ही
अच्छे से फिनिश करना कनेक्शन को क्लोज
करना ठीक है यह अगर आपने जो मेरे
स्टूडेंट्स उनको पता होगा शायद है ना ठीक
है चलिए तो यह तो आपको समझ में आ गया यहां
पर हमने क्या किया भैया हमने यहां पर
टीसीपी का सिन टीसीपी क्या यूज किया
टीसीपी
सिन सेम चीज आपको स्कैनिंग में अगर आप
आपको
टीसीपी एसी के डिस्कवरी करनी है
एक्नॉलेजमेंट वाली तो सेम आपको वही काम
करना है कुछ नहीं मैं आपको बस ये नॉलेज के
लिए बता रहा हूं गाइस ये बस नॉलेज के लिए
यहां पे हाइ फन प ए लगा देना
है हाइ फन हाइ फन रीजन लगा
दीजिए
एंड एक्नॉलेजमेंट के लिए ट्स इट हो गया जब
आप अब आपको ये क्या करेगा होस्ट डिस्कवरी
करेगा एंड आपको रिजल्ट प्रोवाइड कर देगा
ये देखिए यहां
पे हां हान ए तो लगाया ही नहीं भाई हान
sn4 स्कैनिंग बंद कर दी जाए नहीं तो बहुत
टाइम लग जाएगा तो हमने यहां पे हान पए लगा
दिया अब हम एंटर करेंगे और ये हमें
रिजल्ट्स प्रोवाइड करेगा तो इस तरीके से
रिजल्ट आ गया देख सकते हैं आप यहां पे एयर
पे रिस्पांस एयर पे रिस्पांस ये रिजल्ट
हमारे पास आ गया कि कौन-कौन सा भैया अप है
कौन-कौन सा डाउन है दैट्ची है इसमें आप
हान वीवीवी लगा सकते हो वीवी थोड़ा वर्वस
मोड के लिए थोड़ा दिखाएगा हर एक चीज
डिस्कवर किया क्या किया यह सब मतलब जो भी
चीज है वो सारी चीज दिखाएगा आवी लगा दोगे
तो थोड़ा डिटेल में आपको यह आउटपुट देगा
तो यहां पर आप देख सकते हैं होस्ट डाउन नो
रिस्पांस डाउन यहां पर आप देख सकते हो
होस्ट जज अप रिसीवड एर रिस्पांस बाकी जो
जो डाउन है वो डाउन है भैया जो अप है वो
अप में आपको दिखा रहा है यहां प यह होस्ट
अप य होस्ट इज अप य होस्ट इज अप इस तरीके
से आता है ठीक है समझ में आ गया
चलिए बढ़िया अब चलते हैं हम अपने
नेक्स्ट
नेक्स्ट तरीके
का तरीके को देखते हैं एंड यह जो है
यूडीपी
स्कै यूडीपी होस्ट
डिस्कवरी सॉरी
सॉरी सही बात है हैकर फीलिंग के लिए हान व
लगाइए सॉरी सॉरी अभ यूडी पे यूडीपी में
क्या होता है ना कंप्लीट क्या हो जाता है
कंप्लीट अपोजिट सॉरी कंप्लीट अपोजिट हो
जाता
है कंप्लीट अपोजिट क्या होता है जब कोई
क्लाइंट सर्वर
को मान लो यूडीपी पैकेट भेजता है तो सर्वर
रिस्पांस ही नहीं देगा उस केस में आप समझ
सकते हैं कि सर्वर अप है ऐसा समझ सकते हैं
अगर रिस्पांस नहीं दे रहा है तो लेट्स
सपोज कोई रिस्पांस नहीं दे रहा है लेट्स
सपोज आपको पहले रिस्पांस मिलता था तो वहां
पर होस्ट अप था नहीं मिल रहा है तो यहां
पर आपको समझना है कि वहां कुछ ना कुछ है
क्योंकि यूडीपी
आपके पैकेट डिलीवरी का ठेका लेकर नहीं
रखता है उसको नहीं पता उसको नहीं मतलब है
पैकेट डिलीवर हुआ नहीं हुआ एरर रिपोर्टिंग
इन सब से कोई लेना देना यूडीपी का नहीं
है कोई भी लेना देना
नहीं अब यहां पर यूडीपी अगर मान लो कोई
ऐसा
पोर्ट
कोई ऐसा
पोर्ट आपको क्लोज आ रहा है तो यहां आ
जाएगा आपका पोर्ट अनरीचेबल
पोर्ट अनरीचेबल
अगर नहीं है
तो ठीक है अब देखिए यहां यहां पर यूडीपी
स्कैनिंग पर चलते हैं यहां पर लेट्स सपोज
यहां पर यह
वाला यह यूडीपी डिस्कवरी ऑन पोर्ट ठीक है
हा इससे हा एक चीज और मैं आपको बताना
चाहता हूं एक चीज और आप थोड़ा सा ध्यान
दीजिएगा गाइस यह देखिए आपको एक टास्क की
तरह ही आप समझ लीजिए ट्राई हैक
मी समझ
लीजिएगा ट्राई हैक मी प आप आएंगे यहां पर
एंड यहां पर ट्राई हैक मी
में लर्न प आ जाइएगा यहां पर उसके बाद
नीचे आ जाइएगा यहां पर आपको ए मैप का एक
मॉड्यूल मिल जाएगा सेपरेट मॉड्यूल इस ए
मैप पे आ जाइएगा ए मैप पे आप आएंगे तो
आपको यहां पे मान लो यह एक होस्ट डिस्कवरी
का सेक्शन है ठीक है होस्ट डिस्कवरी आप इस
होस्ट डिस्कवरी वाले सेक्शन को उसके अलावा
जो भी सेक्शंस है बेसिक पोर्ट स्कैन
एडवांस पोर्ट स्कैन पोस्ट पोर्ट स्कैन यह
सारे जो है आप ट्राई कीजिएगा कंप्लीट करने
का एंड पूरी कंप्लीट कर लीजिएगा अगर आप यह
लैब करना चाहते हैं तो प्लीज इसको कंप्लीट
कर लीजिएगा ठीक है तो यहां पे भी आपको
यहां पे नेट यूजिंग टीसीपी यडी मिल जाएगी
जो जो चीजें बेसिकली अ यहां पे आपको ये
देखिए यहां पे जो चीजें है जो बेसिकली जो
चीजें मैं आपको बता रहा हूं ऑलमोस्ट वही
चीजें मिलेगी क्योंकि एक ही चीज होती है
अगर जो कमांड लगाओगे वही कमांड है जो
चीजें करोगे वही चीजें हैं तो यहां पे
आपको दिख रहा होगा कि टीसीपी एसीके का ये
अलग-अलग थोड़ा सा और भी कुछ-कुछ चीजें हैं
यहां पे एंड यहां पे ये देखिए ये यूडीपी
पिंग हो रहा है डिस्कवर द होस्टेज ऑनलाइन
यहां पे सेंडिंग अ यूडीपी पैकेट टू एन ओपन
पोर्ट इज नॉट एक्सपेक्टेड टू लीड एनी
रिप्लाई मतलब कोई पोर्ट ओपन है मैंने वही
आपको बताया यहां पे सिंपल कि अगर कोई
पोर्ट ओपन है तो कोई भी रिप्लाई आपको नहीं
आएगा हाउ एवर इफ यी सेंड अ यूडीपी पैकेट
टू अ क्लोज्ड यूडीपी पोर्ट वी एक्सपेक्ट
टू गेट एन आईसीएमपी पोर्ट अनरीचेबल पैकेट
जो मैं आपको यहां पे सिंपल बता रहा था सेम
चीजें हैं तो आप क्या कीजिएगा कि इस वाले
मॉड्यूल को इस वाले मॉड्यूल को एनम पॉली
मॉड्यूल को पूरा कंप्लीट जो है वो कंप्लीट
कर लीजिएगा पूरा ही सॉल्व कर लीजिएगा आपको
बहुत कुछ जानने को मिल जाएगा बाकी
कांसेप्ट समझाने की बात है जो भी चीज है
ये आपका टास्क है वो मैं आपको समझा रहा
हूं बता रहा हूं वो आप वहां से समझ जाएंगे
ठीक है ट्स इट
चलिए
ओके
ओके ओके बहुत बढ़िया अगर पहले से कर लिया
है तो बहुत अच्छी बात है बहुत अच्छी बात
है तो यहां पर यूडीपी के केस में क्या हो
जाता है जैसे कि मैंने आपको बताया यहां पर
कि अगर कोई मैसेज रिप्लाई नहीं आता है
रिप्लाई नो रिप्लाई तो यहां पर समझा जाता
है कि पोर्ट आपका ओपन है या अगर पोर्ट
अनरीचेबल का आता है तो पोर्ट इज क्लोज्ड
ऐसा माना जाता है अनरीचेबल आ रहा है तो
पोर्ट क्लोज्ड है अगर ओपन है तो कोई
रिप्लाई देखने को जनरली आपको नहीं मिलने
वाला है सिंपल सा फंडा है अब इसके आ
जाइएगा चीट शीट के ऊपर में तो हाइन प य
कमांड यूज करना है या आप बोलिए ऑप्शन यूज
करना है तो सेम चीज हम करते
हैं बहुत बढ़िया सेम चीज हम करते हैं सेम
कमांड एंड यहां पे हाइन प य लगा देते हैं
एक जगह पे एंड एंटर करते हैं अब देखिए
यहां पे जब आप एंटर करेंगे तो अभी आप
देखिए जस्ट
वेट
देखिएगा ये देखिए यहां पे जब हमने एंटर
किया यहां पे ये देखिए यहां पे अ ऊपर चलते
हैं ऊपर चलते हैं यहां पे यहां पे ये
देखिए रिसीवड ए आरपी रिस्पांस ऊपर चलते
हैं होस्ट डाउन होस्ट डाउन यहां पे रिसीवड
ए आरपी रिस्पांस नो रिस्पांस यहां पे
होस्ट यहां पे इस तरीके से रिस्पांस आ गया
एंड बेसिक
अगर आप रीजन वगैरह यह सब चीजें नहीं लगाते
हैं मान लो इस तरीके से करते हैं जैसे मैं
आपको दिखा देता हूं लेट्स सपोज आई एम नॉट
यूजिंग एनी रीजन और समथिंग लाइक दैट यह सब
मैं यूज नहीं कर रहा हूं मैं ओनली हान एस
यूज कर रहा हूं नो पोर्ट स्कैनिंग ओनली
होस्ट डिस्कवरी एंड देन एंटर करते
हैं तो यहां पर इस तरीके से आपके सामने
रिजल्ट जो है वो आके होके आ जाती है अब
सेम चीज अगर मैं यहां
पर ग पे करूं न प
google.com तो यहां पर दिख रहा होगा यहां
पर देखो क्या आ रहा है यहां पे कुछ कुछ भी
नहीं आ रहा आपको रिस्पांस में रिस्पांस
में क्या आ रहा है हो सिम्स डाउन बट ऐसा
कुछ है तो नहीं ना इफ इट इज रियली अप बट
ब्लॉकिंग और पिंग प्रोब्स ट्राई हाइन पीएन
तो यहां पर अगर हम हाइन पीएन लगा देते हैं
पी एन तो देखिए पीएन क्या करता है देखिए
यहां प चीट शीट में आपको सब मिल जाएगा
यहां प हान पीए डिसेबल होस्ट डिस्कवरी
पोर्ट स्कैन ओनली तो ये क्या काम करता है
कि ये सिर्फ पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करता है एंड
दैट्ची तो अब देखो एन मैप क्या करता है यह
बात को आप समझो एन मैप क्या करता है बाय
डिफॉल्ट
डीएनएस या रिवर्स डीएनएस करता है बाय
डिफॉल्ट रिवर्स डीएनएस करता है आपका एन
मैप जो है
ना एन
मैप
डज
डीएनएस रिवर्स डीएनएस बाय डिफॉल्ट रिवर्स
डीएनएस का मतलब पता ही है ड ड मेन से आईपी
तो आईपी से डोमेन लेने का यह रिवर्स नस
करता है बट अगर आप हाइन ए लगा देते हैं
किसी भी स्कैनिंग में तो यह इसको रोक देता
है ये इसको बंद कर देता है बस इतना सा
फंडा है समझ में आ गया इतना बहुत सिंपल सा
फंडा है चलिए अब यहां पे थोड़ा सा हम कुछ
तूफानी करते हैं और उसके पहले एक कांसेप्ट
जो और है वह समझ लेते हैं देन उसके बाद
तूफानी करेंगे ठीक है
चलिए जब भी आप पोर्ट स्कैनिंग कर रहे
हो जब भी आप पोर्ट स्कैनिंग कर रहे हो
तो जब भी आप पोर्ट स्कैनिंग कर रहे हो तो
इसके आपको कुछ स्टेट्स दिखेंगे पोर्ट्स के
कि पोर्ट ओपन है या पोर्ट क्लोज है यह
सारे स्टेट्स आपको दिखेंगे तो कितने सारे
स्टेट्स दिखते हैं सबसे पहला आपको यह पता
चलेगा कि पोर्ट ओपन है दूसरा आपको पता
चलेगा कि पोर्ट या तो ओपन है या या क्लोज
है तीसरा आपको पता चलेगा
पोर्ट फिल्टर्ड है चौथा आपको पता चलेगा
पोर्ट अनफिल्टर्ड
पांचवा आपको पता चलेगा पोर्ट ओपन फिल्टर्ड
है छठा आपको पता चलेगा पोर्ट
क्लोज
फिल्टर्ड सिंपल तो ये आपको स्टेट्स है
बेसिकली पोर्ट्स के दो ही
स्टेट होते हैं
ओपन और
क्लोज सिंपल अब ओपन क्लोज में यह सारे छ
और हो गए ओपन होंगे क्लोज होंगे फिल्टर्ड
होंगे अनफिल्टर्ड होंगे ओपन फिल्टर्ड
होंगे क्लोज फिल्टर्ड
होंगे सिंपल तो अब इन्ही स्टेट्स को देख
के हमें पता करना है ओपन है यानी कि यहां
कोई सर्विस चल रही है ओपन
मींस
सम सर्विस
इज रनिंग क्लोज नो
सर्विस फिल्टर्ड का मतलब क्या है इसका
मतलब है फिल्टर्ड का कि यहां एन मैप को
नहीं पता कि यह पोर्ट क्लोज है या ओपन है
क्लोज और ओपन ड्यू टू फायरवॉल कोई फायरवॉल
या कोई सिक्योरिटी उसकी वजह से नहीं
पता सिंपल ए को पता ही नहीं है फिल्टर्ड
का मतलब है पोर्ट एक्सेसिबल तो है बट ए
मैप को नहीं पता कि पोर्ट ओपन है या क्लोज
है ओपन फिल्टर्ड एन मैप को नहीं पता कि
पोर्ट ओपन है या फिल्टर्ड है एंड क्लोज
फिल्टर्ड एप को नहीं पता कि पोर्ट क्लोज
है या फिल्टर्ड है
सिंपल यही सारे स्टेट्स है आपके बस सिंपल
सा फंडा आप सबको समझ में तो आ रहा है ना
भाई बताइए मुझे एवरीवन गेटिंग समझ में आ
रहा है भैया देख रहा हूं मैं जल्दी से बता
दीजिए कि दिमाग से निकल रहा है भाई
मेरे प्लीज शीरे एनम चीट शीट मैं शीरे
कैसे करूं शेयर मैंने ऑलरेडी किया है डिफ
अकेडमी ए प पर जाइए फ्री कोर्स वाले में
आइए और वहां कंटेंट में आपको ए का चीट शट
मिल जाएगा
सिंपल लोग ठीक है बराबर समझ में आ रहा
है ध्यान
रखिएगा ओपन फिल्टर्ड का मतलब एन मैप को
नहीं पता कि य पोर्ट ओपन है कि फिल्टर्ड
सिंपल ठीक
है नहीं बस इतने ही होते हैं बस इतने ही
होते जो सामने लिखा छ छ के छ जो लिखा वही
उतना ही होते है बस ठीक है ये छ स्टेट है
जनरली अभी अभी मैं आपको जो बता रहा हूं
नाना याद रखिएगा यह कांसेप्ट है अभी तो हम
बग बाउंट में इसको यूज करने वाले हैं
प्रैक्टिकल अभी करेंगे अब स्टार्ट होगा
हमारा प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट क्योंकि बिना
प्रैक्टिकल के आपको तो यार मजा आता नहीं
है तो उसको कैसे छोड़ सकते हैं यही बात है
छोड़ना भी पॉसिबल नहीं है तो चलिए अब मैं
क्या करता हूं आई एम गोइंग टू स्टार्ट माय
माय सुपर फास्ट मशीन ऑन ऑन ऑन कहां पे
डिजिटल ओसियन पे मेरा वीपीएस है मेरा
क्लाउड मशीन है मैं इसको स्टार्ट कर रहा
हूं ऑलरेडी स्टार्ट है अगर आपको भी इस पे
क्लाउड मशीन अ डिजिटल ओसन की क्लाउड मशीन
यूज़ करनी है तो यह बहुत ही सुपर फास्ट और
बहुत ही अफोर्डेबल रेट में आपको मिल जाता
है इसी वीडियो इसी लाइव से क्लास के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको मेरा रेफरल लिंक
मिलेगा उससे आप साइन अप करिए आपको इस तरह
से एक $200 का क्रेडिट मिलेगा एंड 60 डेज
के लिए मेरे 43 डेज अब रह चुके हैं और $88
बचे हुए हैं अभी 200 में से ठीक है देखो
इतने दिन से यूज़ कर रहा हूं मैं बहुत कम
यूटिलाइज हो रहा है तो डिस्क्रिप्शन में
लिंक है वहां से साइन अप कर लीजिएगा मैं
अब यहां पर इस मशीन से कनेक्ट कर लेता हूं
लेट मी सी मेरे पास फिजिक्स वाला का कॉल आ
रहा है
हेलो ओके
सॉरी चलिए तो यहां पे अब मैं इसको अपने
मोबा एक्सटम से कनेक्ट कर लेता हूं मेरे
भैया मोबा एक्सटम
भैया लेट्स कनेक्ट एक्सक्यूट
इट टक टक टक
टक
क्या हुआ
भैया कुछ कुछ कार्ड्स सपोर्ट नहीं करती है
तो नहीं हो रहा होगा ये क्या हो रहा है
भाई व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग यह बंद है क्या
यार अच्छा अच्छा यह बंद किया होगा मैंने
स्टार्ट तो कि पहले का ही होगा शायद ये
अच्छा बंद है ये ऑन करो यार ऑन
करो ऑन कर रहा हूं मैं य ऑन था ही नहीं
मैं वैसे ही कनेक्ट कर रहा हूं मैं सोच
रहा हूं कि क्या हो क्या रहा है यार ऑन
कनेक्ट क्यों नहीं हो रहा क्या दिक्कत आ
गई अब हम टारगेट प हंट करने वाले हैं हंट
करने वाले हैं टारगेट पे अब हम लाइव हंट
करने वाले हैं
हंटिंग
अरे ना भाई नमस्ते नमस्ते आई एम न्यू हियर
वेलकम गेमजी
वर्ल्ड बद सर बैकग्राउंड में अदरक कूटा जा
रहा है अरे हां भाई तो घर है यार घर पर
काम तो होंगे ही ना यार क्या अदरक खाने है
क्या तुम्हें बैकग्राउंड
में मैं क्या उनकी प्रमोशन करूंगा यार वो
करेंगे मेरा चलो यहां मैं रीस्टार्ट करता
हूं सेशन को नाउ इट्स डन एंड लेट्स
कनेक्ट या वी आर कनेक्टेड नाउ हियर ऑसम
बहुत बढ़िया अब आपको याद होगा तो प्रीवियस
सेशन जो हमने लिए हुए थे भैया जी उसमें
मैंने आपको पोर्ट्स जो है ना सॉरी आईपी जो
है वो कलेक्ट किए थे वो प्रीवियस सेशन कौन
सा था भैया ये वाला बग बाउंट की क्लास
नंबर 15 इसमें हमने आईपीस को कलेक्ट किए
थे राइट एलएस करूंगा मैं एलएस करूंगा तो
यहां पे एल नाम की डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री सीडी
एल में चलता हूं और एलस करूंगा तो मुझे
यहां पे मैं इसको क्या करता हूं
ना जूम कर लेता हूं ऐसे मतलब फुल स्क्रीन
कर लेता हूं यहां एलस करूंगा तो यहां पे
एल
आईपी डटी एक्टी मुझे मिल जाती है आईपी
एड्रेसस मिल जाती है ठीक है तो क एल आईटी
एकटी करेंगे यहां पे तो एल ये जो आईपी है
एल वाली ये मुझे यहां पे आईपी जो है वो
मिल गई है कितनी आई भैया इस वाले में एक
बार चलिए देख लेते हैं तो यहां पर डब्लू
सफन एल टारगेट की आईपी आपको मिल ग 16384
बहुत ज्यादा है तो एल आईपी 2 में चलिए
सॉरी एल आईपी ू में देखते हैं कितने आईपी
है 2048 ठीक है आई पटू या इट विल बी फाइन
तो यहां पर आईपी टू जो है वह थोड़ा ठीक
है एल आईपी लार्ज भी आईपी लार्ज इसमें है
भैया अरे बाप रे बहुत है तो app2 जो है वो
वाला हमारा इसको हम ले लेते हैं अब क्या
है ए मैप में ना आप बेसिकली गाइस ए मैप के
अंदर एक लिस्ट भी पास कर सकते
हो हां छोटी कंपनीज की आईपी अ ज्यादा नहीं
मिलेगी आपको बिल्कुल सही बात है नहीं
मिलेगी छोटी कंपनी की ज्यादा आईपी आईपी
मतलब रेंज नहीं होता ना यार सीआईडीआर
बेसिकली उनके पास एक नेटवर्क रेंज या फिर
आईपी ब्लॉक्स नहीं होते हैं ज्यादा तो
कहां से मिलेगी राइट ए मैप में आप हान आईल
यह कमांड देके एक टारगेट की लिस्ट को भी
अप्लाई कर सकते हो एंड उसपे फर्द जो काम
है वह कर सकते हो तो मैं यहां पे क्या कर
रहा हूं ए मैप कमांड यूज कर रहा हूं अगर
आपको नहीं पता तो एप्ट इंस्टॉल ए मैप कर
लीजिएगा डेन के अंदर भी शायद आपके u2 के
अंदर भी ये इंस्टॉल हो जाएगा
दैट्ची है अब उसके बाद न आल सॉरी अब यहां
प मैं वो दे दूंगा एल
i2t ये वाली आईपीस को दे रहे हैं हम हम
यहां पे क्या करने वाले हैं हम यहां पे
सिंपल सा हम यहां पे होस्ट डिस्कवरी करते
हैं सिंपल होस्ट डिस्कवरी करें क्या सिंपल
कि कौन सा आईपी अप है कौन सा डाउन है यह
तो देखना पड़ेगा ना भाई तो पहले हम वो काम
कर लेते हैं तो
app2 हान
प यह कर दे हान प करें या क्या करें हम
यहां पे सिंपल क्या करने वाले हैं देखिए
हान पीआर जब हम करते हैं देखिए यहां पे
हाइन पीआर तो यह ए आरपी डिस्कवरी करता है
आपके लोकल नेटवर्क पे ठीक है अगर हम हाइन
ए लगा देते हैं तो यह डिसेबल पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग करता
है पोर्ट स्कैनिंग डिसेबल करके ओनली आपका
डिस्कवरी
करेगा जिन में य कर सकते बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
जन मैप भी कर सकते कोई दिक्कत नहीं तो हम
य पर हाइन पीर लगा दो फिर हाइन एस ए लगा
दो
सिंपल
एंड बाय डिफॉल्ट
आपका यह देखो यहां पे नीचे आ जाओ नीचे आ
जाओ नीचे आ जाओ नीचे आ जाओ कहीं ना कहीं
तो दिख जाएगा तुम्हें हाइन ए दिख रहा है
कफन
ए हान ए आपको यहां नहीं दिख रहा है
बट यह रहा हान ए नेवर डू डीएनएस
रेजोल्यूशन बाय डिफॉल्ट ये डीएनएस
रेजोल्यूशन करता है यह अच्छी बात है तो हम
इसको वैसे ही रहने देते हैं कोई दिक्कत
नहीं और एंटर करते हैं लेट्स सी व्हाट इज
द आउटपुट वी आर गोइंग टू गेट लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज द आउटपुट वी आर
गेटिंग लेट्स वेट इट्स डूइंग डूइंग
डूइंग
या पब्लिक नेटवर्क है हां क्या दिक्कत है
तो देखते हैं क्या होता
है लेट्स सी व्ट इज
हैपनिंग देखते हैं भैया देखते
हैं 2.93 डन ओनली
2.93 पर डन भाई क्यों ओ हो हो हो देख रहे
हो कितने सारे होस्ट 2048 होस्ट को कर रहा
है तो थोड़ा टाइम तो लगेगा
3.72 ये थोड़ा सा टाइम लगेगा यहां पे मैं
यहां पर एक काम करते हैं यहां पर व्हाट वी
आर गोइंग टू डू यहां पर कुछ ज्यादा ही
आईपी एड्रेस हो गई
है यहां पर कुछ ज्यादा आईपी एड्रेस हो गई
है एक काम करता हूं मैं ऐसे कर लेता हूं
आईपी एडस तो ठीक है बट लेट मी डू वन थिंग
मैं यहां पे हाइ फन पीआर हटा देता हूं
हाइन एस एन लगा देते हैं ठीक है कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं है एंड यहां पर हम हाइन
हाइन हाइन वीवी वर्वस मोड जो लगा देते हैं
ताकि हमें दिखता चले तो थोड़ा सा सही
रहेगा
हम जस्ट
वेट यह
देखिए चल रहा है ये यहां पे हमने डिसेबल
होस्ट डिस्कवरी डिसेबल पोर्ट स्कैन किया
हुआ है यहां पे हान ए लगाया है डिसेबल
पोर्ट स्कैनिंग पोर्ट स्कैनिंग हम नहीं कर
रहे हैं ओनली होस्ट डिस्कवरी कर रहे हैं
दैट्ची पी के लिए तो हाइन पीएस पीए यह सब
लगा सकते हैं अगर आपको करना है तो ठीक है
बस
दैट्ची या या यहां पर आप देखिए यहां पर
स्टट्स गोइंग ऑन 4
पर 5
पर थोड़ा सा टाइम लगता है अगर आपको थोड़ा
सा टाइम देना ही पड़ेगा बिना उसके नहीं कर
सकते
आप देखो यह मैप है ठीक है ना इसलिए एन मैप
का यूज नहीं किया जाता है आईपी देखो यह एन
मैप है ना यह देख रहा है कितना टाइम आपको
लग रहा है इसलिए एन मैप का यूज नहीं किया
जाता है होस्ट डिस्कवरी के लिए नहीं किया
जाता है इसके जगह पर मास डीएनएस सॉरी मास
स्कैन का यूज किया जाता है यही रीजन है
भाई यह समझ में आ रहा है आपको कि क्या
रीजन है कि मास स्कैन का यूज किया जाता है
यही रीजन है क्योंकि यह देखिए टाइमिंग
देखिए टाइमिंग देखो
भाई
अभी तक यह अभी तक यह इतना टाइम लगा रहा
है समझ में आ रहा
है एवरीवन
गेटिंग चलिए अब स्लो है ना स्लो है अब ये
सेम काम हम बंद करते हैं यहां पे वी आर
जस्ट क्लोजिंग इट एंड यहां मास
स्कैन यहां हम यूज करते हैं मास स्कैन
हाइन एच ये वाला यूज करते हैं और अब हम
क्या करते हैं देखो मास स्कैन में याद
रखिएगा
आप लिस्ट दोज ऑप्शंस दैट आर कंपैटिबल विथ
ए मैप हान हान ए मैप लगा देता हूं मैं
यहां पे एंड यहां पे वो ऑप्शंस आ जाएंगे
जो आप ए मैप वाले इसके साथ यूज कर सकते
हैं तो यहां पर आप देख रहे होगा हाइन आईल
यह भी आप डाल सकते हैं एक लिस्ट डाल सकते
हैं तो चलिए मैं क्या कर देता हूं हान आईल
कर दिया उसके बाद पोर्ट पोर्ट रेंज वगर आप
डिफाइन कर सकते हैं अगर आपको दिखाना है
अभी पोर्ट त कुछ करना नहीं य पे उसके बाद
नीचे आ जाते हैं नीचे आ जाते हैं रिज्यूम
है नवी है ठीक है तो ट्स इट तो चलिए यहां
पर अब चलते हैं य प मास स्कैन
हाइन आई एल यह दे हमने अब यहां पे पास
देना है एल
i2t एकटी ये हमने एल i2t एकटी दे दिया मास
स्कैन के अंदर में अब मास स्कैन के अंदर
में हम पोर्ट स्कैनिंग चलाएंगे हम बेसिकली
होस्ट डिस्कवरी ये चलाएंगे करेंगे तो अब
देखिए कैसे करना है अब उसके बाद आप क्या
करेंगे पोर्ट का कोई ऐसा कोई हमें डिफाइन
नहीं करना है कुछ ऐसा तो हम रहने देते हैं
बैनर्स वगैरह ये सब कुछ करना नहीं है हमें
और कुछ हमें यहां पे चाहिए नहीं नहीं यहां
पे हम रेट लगा सकते हैं रेट आपको बढ़ाना
है डिफॉल्ट जो है वो 10 केब केपी पीएस है
बट यहां पे रेट को आप बढ़ा सकते हैं घटा
सकते हैं फिलहाल के लिए मैं इतना रहने
देता हूं एंड हान ईन रेट इज इक्वल टू 5000
कर देता
हूं ठीक है न आफ रेट इज इक्वल टू सही है
ना हां ये कर दिया और मैं अब एंटर करता
हूं लेट्स सी हां जब मैंने ये कर दिया अब
यहां पे यह बता रहा है यह बोल रहा है कि
कोई पोर्ट स्पेसिफाई कीजिए तो यहां पे हम
पोर्ट को भी स्पेसिफाई कर देंगे कोई सा भी
पोर्ट आपको स्पेस करना है आप पोर्ट को
स्पेसिफाई कर दीजिए सारे पोर्ट्स के लिए
करना है सारे पोर्ट्स के लिए कर दीजिए तो
मैं यहां पर क्या करता हूं आई एम गोइंग टू
आस्क कि यह पर्टिकुलर 80 और 443 पोर्ट इस
पर आप ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं या किसी भी
पोर्ट प आप ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं रिचे बल
है कि नहीं है यह पर्टिकुलर तो मैं यहां प
हाइन हाइन पोर्ट्स एंड यहां पर मैं जीरो
से लेकर सारे आप डाल सकते हैं जितने भी
पोर्ट्स है वो सारे डाल सकते हैं या तो आप
पर्टिकुलर
कमा 443 एंड एंटर कर द अब आप एंटर करेंगे
तो अब यह क्या
करेगा स्कैन करेगा देख लीजिए यहां
पर जीरो एंड ट्स इट यहां पर आपको यह
रिजल्ट आपको प्रोवाइड
करेगा बट रिजल्ट हमें सही मिला नहीं है
लेट्स वेट यहां पर मैं सारे पोर्ट्स को कर
लेता हूं पोर्ट्स यहां पर 0 टू 65
5 सारे पोर्ट्स पर कर लेते हैं एक बार एंड
हाइन व लगा देते हैं लेट्स
सी ओके नाउ यहां पर यह स्टार्ट कर चुका
है डन डन डन कर रहा यह काम
अपना अभी आएंगे हम रियल वर्ल्ड पलेस जल्दी
आएंगे ठीक है जल्दी आएंगे सो इट डूइंग
इट्स वक यहां पे इतना परसेंट रिमेनिंग
इतना परसेंट रिमेनिंग इतना परसेंट डन ये
थोड़ा लाइक बहुत ज्यादा आईपीस के कारण हो
जा रहा है बट कोई बात
नहीं मतलब बेसिकली ये स्कैन करेगा एंड
टोटली तो मैं एक काम करता हूं मैं इसको
बहुत टाइम लग जाएगा इसको मैं क्लोज कर
देता हूं एंड एक काम करते यहां पे हम यहां
पे ए मैप जो चला रहे हैं यहां पे ए मैप
यहां पे हम क्या कर देते हैं मैं यहां पे
क्या कर देता हूं ए मैप चलाते हैं एंड
इसके बाद मैं एक काम करता हूं आई एम गोइंग
टू प्रोवाइड एन आईपी मैं एक आईपी पे
डिस्कवरी करता हूं पोर्ट्स का ठीक है तो
मुझे क्या करना है जैसे मैंने ए मैप चलाया
मेरे पास एक आईपी है कोई सी भी एक आईपी ले
लो जो ओपन क्लोज जो भी है ए मैप लिया हमने
एंड यहां पे मैंने लिस्ट ऑफ आईपी के लिए
हान आल कर दिया एंड एंड यहां पर हमने दे
दिया
एल क्या बात
है बताया तो था यार वो नॉट वो
टेस्ट टेस्ट क्रेडेंशियल थे एल आ2 एक्सटी
एंड यहां पे हम दे देते
हैं डिसेबल पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग ए आर प यूज कर लेते हैं यहां
पे ठीक है
दैट्ची
एक काम करते हैं ना इसकी थोड़ी सी स्पीड
बढ़ा देते हैं नवी हाइन
टी मैं टी बेसिकली फ कर दूं
t5 ट
सी एग्रेसिव स्कैन थोड़ा कर दे रहे हैं
हम थोड़ा टाइम लगेगा क्योंकि काफी ज्यादा
है अभी मैं आपको दिखाऊंगा सर
बीवी सर बीबी बगवां प्रोग्राम में कुछ
पैकेट लिमिट या रिक्वेस्ट पर सेकंड रहता
है क्या है वह मतलब वो तो सिक्योरिटीज है
रेट लिमिट्स होती है कई
सारी अभी हम देखेंगे अभी वो भी देखेंगे
बहुत कुछ देखने वाले हैं जस्ट लेट्स जस्ट
लेट्स
वेट
7 पर हुआ थोड़ा फास्ट हो रहा है यह इट्स
लिटिल बिट फास्ट 12 पर हो रहा है यहां पे
देखो यहां पे 12 पर हो रही
है क्योंकि हमने टी फ कर दिया है थोड़ा
फास्ट है 15 पर वेट वेट वेट वेट वेट थोड़ा
वेट कर लेते हैं बहुत ज्यादा आईपी है ना
यार समझ रहे हो
ना
अभी हम लाइव टारगेट पर भी आ जाएंगे लाइव
टारगेट तो हालाकि यही है बट
स्टिल 72 पर हो चुकी
है 72 पर हो चुका है ल लेट्स
वेट
यह
देखिए कंप्लीटेड डीएनएस रेजोल्यूशन
स्टार्ट हो रहा है यहां पर मैंने आपको
बताया था बाय डिफॉल्ट य करता
है रिवर्स डीएनएस सो लेट्स वेट 10 के होने
वाले सब्सक्राइबर्स क्या बात है यार यह
देखिए यह देखिए यहां पर रिजल्ट आ गया
हमारे पास यह रिजल्ट आ गया हमारे पास
होस्ट डाउन रिसीव नो रिस्पांस होस्ट डाउन
यह देखिए होस्ट डाउन होस डाउन होस डाउन
सारे होस्ट डाउन ही है क्या
भाई
सब होस्ट डाउन है यह क्या है यह देखो
स्कैन रिपोर्ट फॉर इतना एक होस्ट अप है यह
एक आपको होस्ट मिला जो अप है इतने सारे
होस्ट में चलो इसको मैंने कॉपी किया एंड
इसको हम यहां पेस्ट कर लेते हैं यह जो
होस्ट अप है और देख लेते
हैं होस्ट जज अ एक हमें मिला है
भैया
यह देखो यह भी है यह सारे होस्ट भी अप हैं
यह सारे होस्ट भी अप हैं तो अच्छी बात है
यहां पे कुछ होस्ट हमें एटलीस्ट मिल तो
रहे हैं कि जो अप है यहां पे तो वी हैव सम
वी हैव अनदर होस्ट दैट इज अप यहां पे ओके
यह सारे होस्ट जो है होस्ट इज अप रिसीव
रिसेट टीटीएल ठीक है ना होस्ट इज अप होस्ट
इज अप तो यह हमने क्या किया बेसिकली हमने
यहां
पे यह चलाया हमारा ए मैप चलाया और एक
टारगेट ऑफ आईपी की यहां पे होस्ट डिस्कवरी
यहां पे कर ली होस्ट अप है डाउन है या
व्हाट एवर जो भी है यहां पे हमने यहां पे
वो चीज फिनिश कर ली
दैट्ची है अब मैं यहां पे क्या करता हूं
गाइस देखिए अब क्या है अब मैं डोमस पे आता
हूं चलिए अब डोमेन पे ये तो हमने आईपी प
देख लिया हमें कुछ लाइव आईपी भी मिल गई है
अब मेरे पास मान लो टेस्ला के लाइव डोमस
है कितने डोमस है भैया लाइव कैट लाइव डोमस
डब्लू सफन एल मेरे पास 485 लाइव डोमेंस है
टेस्ला के अब मैं इस पर ट्राई करूंगा क्या
करने का डिस्कवरी करने का कैसे भैया तो ए
मैप हान आल अब यहां पर मैं दे देता हूं
लाइव
डमटी दे दिया अब यहां पे हम सेम चीज करने
वाले हैं हान ए स्कैनिंग को डिसेबल करेंगे
और हाई फन पीआर लगा देंगे किसके लिए भैया
पीआर पीआर ए आरपी डिस्कवरी के लिए बस यह
काम कर लेते हैं एंड
दैट्ची में यह एचटीटीपी लगा हुआ है या फिर
जो पहला था यहां पर लाइव
डोमस लाइव डोम एचटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल लगा हुआ
है ट्स वई ऐसा हुआ है यहां पे ये जो
टारगेट एक्सेप्ट करता है विदाउट एसटीटीपी
करता है तो हमें विदाउट एसटीटीपी वाले जो
डोमन है वो निकाल लेते हैं एक बार तो यहां
पे लाइव डोमस में तो है ऑल सब डोमस ऑल
शॉर्टेड ऑल शॉर्टेड में देख लेते
हैं इसमें नहीं लगा हुआ है ओबवियसली इसमें
नहीं हमारा चलिए ऑल शॉर्टेड जो है इस पर
चल देते हैं इसी को यूज कर लेते हैं तो ऑल
शॉर्टेड में कितने डोमस है हमारे पास भाई
1286 डोमस है हम इसी को अप्लाई करने वाले
हैं तो अब हम क्या करेंगे सेम कमांड में ए
मैप के यहां पे ऑल शॉर्टेड वाली जो लिस्ट
है इसको लगा देते हैं
ऑल शड एक्सटी ठीक
है नमन नमन नमन भीष्म पितामह ठीक है अब
यहां पर कर क्या क्या करते हैं हम एंटर
करते हैं अब
देखिए अब देखिए यह सारे डोमेंस को रिजॉल्व
करने की कोशिश कर रहा है और यह
देखिए होस्ट इज अप होस्ट इज अप होस्ट इज
अप देख रहे हो ये रिजल्ट्स आपको दे रहा है
ये फील ले लो हैकर वाली ये
देखो ये आपको कुछ जो फेल्ड हो जा रहे हैं
रिजॉल्व करने के लिए फेल हो जा रहे हैं
बाकी को जिनको जिनको यह कर पा रहे है
रिजॉल्व वो रिजॉल्व करके आपको यह आईपी के
साथ बता दे है कि होस्ट अप है और आपको
उसकी आईपी भी प्रोवाइड कर दे रहा है जो
पर्टिकुलर आईपी है वो आपको प्रोवाइड कर दे
रहा है देखा यह है कमाल की
चीज हमें आईपी मिल रही हैय पर्टिकुलर
ये
देखो टक टक टक टक टक टक टक गट इट गट इट गट
इट वी गट द आई पीस
देखिए इंटरेस्टिंग है
[संगीत]
ना ये सारे डोमस को जो भी आपके टारगेट
डोमेन है हमारा ए मैप का काम हमारा यही है
ना स्कैनिंग में में कि जो भी डोमेन आईपी
है उसको या तो डोमेन है रिजॉल्व कर दो
आईपी है उस परे ट्राई करो कितने पोर्ट्स
ओपन है क्लोज्ड हैं जो पोर्ट्स ओपन वाले
आईपी है उनको निकालो और उन परे फिर सर्विस
स्कैनिंग करो और देखो कौन सी सर्विस चल
रही है क्या चल रहा है और ट्राई करो फाइंड
करने का कि कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग स्टफ्स कोई पे
कोई ओल्ड सर्विस या कोई वल्नरेबल सर्विस
तो नहीं चल रही है फिर उसको एक्सप्लोइट
अगर कर पाते हो तो यू गेट अ बाउंट
सिंपल
टर्मिनल कलर ग्रीन कर दीजिए और भी मजा
आएगा ओ ग्रीन एंड ब्लैक
देख तो बहुत सारे को रिजॉल्व नहीं कर पा
रहा है बहुत सारे को रिजॉल्व कर रहा है तो
अच्छी बात है रिव करने दो चलिए अब हमारे
पास इनफ डाटा आ चुकी है इनफ आईपी आ चुकी
है मैं यहां पर कंट्रोल सी करके मतलब इसको
रोक रहा
हूं यहां पर मैंने रोक दिया हमारे पास
इतनी आईपी आ चुकी है कि हम अब इसको
सर आई एम न्यू मेरे पास पैट ओस इंस्टॉल्ड
है वीएम में तो क्या मैं उसमें कर सकता
हूं बिल्कुल पैरेट ओएस से भी आप कर सकते
हो कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है अब मेरे पास ये
आईपी आ चुकी है देखिए यहां पे डीएनएस
रिकॉर्ड फॉर इतना ये ए मैप स्कन रिपोर्ट
फॉर सिक्योर गस्ट
[संगीत]
tesla.svs क्या करेंगे हम इस पे जब हमारे
पास आईपी आ चुकी है तो हमारा नेक्स्ट जो
टारगेट है वो
है उस पर्टिकुलर आईपी
पे कौन सी सर्विस चल रही
है कौन सा वर्जन है इसके बारे में
जानना
सिंपल अब इसका कैसे पता चलेगा जब आप एन
मैप चीट शीट में जाएंगे तो यहां पे आप
पोर्ट एक प हां पोर्ट के लिए भी आप जा
सकते हैं मतलब किस पोर्ट के लिए आप स्कैन
कर रहे हैं पर्टिकुलर किस पोर्ट के लिए आप
यह आपने स्कैनिंग चालू की है यह भी आप कर
सकते हैं वर्जंस देखने के लिए भी आप चालू
कर सकते हैं आप पर्टिकुलर वर्जन आपको सारे
ही पोर्ट पे चाहिए वह भी आप कर सकते हैं
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है सारे ही पोर्ट पे ये
कर देगा स्कैन तो चलिए अब क्या करते हैं
यहां पे कुछ आईपी मुझे मिली है यह एल वाली
आईपी
है एंड यहां पे टेस्ला वाली आईपी मुझे
मिली है तो मैं यहां पर कुछ आईपी जो है यह
कलेक्ट कर लेता
हूं
फिनॉप्स इसके सिक्योर गेस्ट यह वाली आईपी
उठा लेते
हैं उसके बाद उसके बाद फाइल्स ओनरशिप यह
वाली आईपी उठा लेते
हैं ठीक है
भैया
थैंक यू हैकर थैंक यू
हैकर उसके बाद एससी सीपीएम यह वाली आईपी
भी उठा लेते हैं आज बग फाइंड होगा क्या हा
क्या पता
भाई
चलिए हमने आईपी उठा ली अब हम यहां पे ए
मैप का फिर से यूज करने वाले हैं एंड बिना
एन मैप के यूज के ये आगे वाला काम आप नहीं
कर सकते हैं तो अब हम क्या करेंगे ए मैप
कमांड डालेंगे एंड यहां पे हम अपनी टारगेट
की आईपी प्रोवाइड कर देंगे तो हम टेस्ला
वाली पहली आईपी उठा लेते हैं मान लो ये
वाली आईपी हमने उठा ली
एंड यहां पर मैंने इसको डाल दिया उसके बाद
जब हमने एन मैप की आई यहां पर हमने दे दी
अब हमें यहां पर क्या लगाना है सिंपल सा
फंडा है हमें सबसे पहले हाइ फन ए ए को
नहीं लगाना है क्योंकि हम पोर्ट स्कैनिंग
कर रहे हैं याद रखिएगा हम यहां पे पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग कर रहे हैं हाइन एस अगर आप लगा
देंगे तो इसका मतलब है डिसेबल पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग ऐसा कुछ नहीं करना है हम हाइन
पीएन जरूर लगा सकते हैं डिसेबल होस्ट
डिस्कवरी जो कि आपको बता आता है कि सिर्फ
पोर्ट स्कैनिंग करनी है तो चलिए हमने हाइन
पीएन लगा दिया सिर्फ पोर्ट स्कैनिंग के
लिए डन अब यहां पर हमें सर्विस
का वर्जन डिटेक्ट करना है इसके लिए नीचे
जब आप आएंगे तो सर्विस एंड वर्जन डिटेक्शन
में यहां पर हाइन एसवी करके एक स्विच है
अटम टू डिटरमाइंड द वर्जन ऑफ द सर्विस
रनिंग ऑन द
पोर्ट यह आपको बताता
है ठीक है
व्ट्स देयर इन द नेम आपको इसलिए नहीं समझ
में आ रहा क्योंकि आपने डे वन से नहीं
अटेंड करी आप डे वन से अटेंड कीजिए आपको
सब समझ में आ जाएगा टेंशन मत लीजिए आप ठीक
है तो हमने यहां पर क्या किया है हाइन
एसवी हमें यहां पर लगाना है हाइन एसवी
सर्विस वर्जन के डिटेक्शन के लिए सिंपल
चलिए यह तो हो गया अब यहां पर आप ए मैप की
स्पीड को भी स्पीड को भी बढ़ा सकते हैं
थोड़ा थोड़ा सा एन में बाय डिफॉल्ट जो है
ना टाइमिंग एंड परफॉर्मेंस वाले सेक्शन
में आइएगा तो बाय डिफॉल्ट t3 को यूज करता
है नॉर्मल t3 डिफॉल्ट स्पीड आप इसको थोड़ा
सा बढ़ा सकते हैं t4 कर सकते हैं t5 कर
सकते हैं व्हाट एवर यू वांट हम यहां पे t4
के साथ जाना पसंद करेंगे तो हाइन
t 4 ठीक है यह आपने काम कर दिया फिलहाल
इतने से इतना सा करके आगे बढ़ते हैं देखते
हैं कुछ अगर कोई दिक्कत आएगी तो देखा
जाएगा एंटर करते हैं लेट्स सी नाउ इट विल
स्टार्ट द स्कैनिंग
प्रोसेस एक पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट पे एक
पर्टिकुलर इस आईपी
पे ठीक है जस्ट वेट थैंक यू ट्यूटोरियल सक
थैंक यू धन्यवाद भाई लेट्स वेट फॉर द
आउटपुट यहां पे आप एंटर मारेंगे तो आपको
इसका दिख जाएगा कि कितना प्रोसेस हुआ है
जैसे मैंने एंटर किया तो यहां पे आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे कि ये अभी तक स्टार्ट
हुआ स्टार्ट हो रहा है यह हो सकता है आईपी
की वजह से भी हो जाए ऐसा होता है आईपी की
वजह से भी होता हु ठीक है ना तो थोड़ा वेट
कीजिए यहां पर मैं एक काम करता हूं मैं
पीएन वाला जो स्विच है इसको हटा देता
हूं देन नॉर्मली
स्कैनिंग पीएन लगा भी सकते हैं कोई दिक्कत
नहीं य पर यह ऑलमोस्ट कंप्लीट होने वाला
है
हाइन वीवी लगा सकते
हैं वर्वस आउटपुट के
लिए थैंक यू भाई थैंक
यू कितने आ गए य पर
ओके ओके स्टिल स्कैनिंग तो हो चुकी है य
पर हान पीन हमने लगा दिया अब य सर्विस
स्कैन कर रहा है ठीक है सर्विस स्कैनिंग
कर रहा है अभी जी पर हुआ
है एंड इट कैन टेक टाइम यह टाइम ले सकता
है सर्विस स्कैनिंग में यहां पर पहले तो
इसने वो होस्ट डिस्कवरी कर ली क्योंकि
हमने हान पीएन नहीं लगाया था होस्ट
डिस्कवरी को बंद नहीं किया था तो इसने
पहले होस्ट डिस्कवरी की यहां पे ये देखो
सिन स्टिल स्कैन पहले किया एंड इसको
कंप्लीट कर लिया अब यहां पे ये सर्विस
स्कैन कर रहा
है हां t5 बहुत फास्ट है t5 आप लगा सकते
हो बट जितना फास्ट करोगे उतनी फाल्स
पॉजिटिव्स जो है ना वो मिलने के चांसेस है
आपको तो इट्स बेटर आप यह वाला यूज कीजिए
हालाकि य थोड़ा सा टाइम लेगा आईपी आईपी टू
भी डिपेंड करता है गाइस तो मैं यहां पर
इसको क्लोज कर रहा हूं ए यहां पर
मैं हान प ए लगा देता हूं एंड ताकि डिसेबल
हो जाए प ए यहां पर मैं t5 करके ही एक बार
t5 पर चेक कर लेते हैं अगर t5 प कुछ आता
है तो चलिए हान वीवी भी लगा देते हैं
वर्वस मोड के लिए लेट्स
सी यह
देखिए डिस्कवर्ड ओपन पोर्ट 443 चलिए अच्छी
बात बात है नॉर्मल सा पोर्ट ओपन है 443
कोई और पोर्ट तो है नहीं यहां पर
डिस्कवर्ड ओपन पोर्ट ठीक
है ठीक है यहां
पर यस
यस फर्स्ट डे से मजा आ गया हैक नाम बताइए
अपना एक बार
ब्रदर यहां पर
देखिए स्टार्ट हो चुकी है यहां पे
आपकी स्कैनिंग वन
सर्विस 0.00
पर सो इट्स ड्यू टू द
[संगीत]
आईपी लेट्स वेट लेट्स वेट लेट्स वेट
आशीष ओके आशीष बहुत बढ़िया चलिए मैं इसको
क्लोज कर देता हूं इट विल टेक टाइम यहां
पे मैं यहां पे अब क्या कर देता हूं
[संगीत]
लेट्स लेट्स चेंज द आईपी चेंज द आईपी यहां
टारगेट चेंज कर देते हैं एन मैप एंड उसके
बाद हम ये वाली आईपी दे देते हैं एप्ल
वाली भैया एल वाली आईपी चलो दे देता एप्ल
वाली आईपी दे दिया कर
दिया एन मैप उसके बाद यहां पर हाइन एसवी
लगा देते हैं एंड यहां पर हाइ फन टी फ लगा
देते
हैं टी फ लगा के हम स्कन मार देते हैं एंड
सर्विस वर्जन के लिए एंड ट्स इट इतना काफी
होना चाहिए मेरे ख्याल से एंड लेट्स प्रेस
हान व लगा ही देते हैं देन एटर
चलिए
फिलहाल स्कैनिंग हो रही
है एंड ट्स इट यहां पर आ चुका है यहां पे
रिजल्ट आपके पास आ चुका यहां पे
स्टार्टिंग रन लेवल ये देखिए यहां पे इसने
फटाक से आपको रिजल्ट दे दिया यहां पे हान
ए भी लगाया था हमने
एंड प्लीज रिपोर्ट एनी इनकरेक्ट रिजल्ट
यहां पे वन आईपी एड्रेस होस्ट अप डाउन या
रॉ पकेट सेंड यहां पे आया है हमें फिलहाल
कुछ भी यहां पे नहीं मिला है नॉट शोन
होस्ट इज अप रिसीवड यहां पे कुछ खास हमें
कुछ मिला नहीं है कोई नॉट शोन 1000
फिल्टर्ड टीसीपी पोर्ट नो रिस्पांस हमें
कुछ भी यहां पे कुछ खास रिस्पांस नहीं
मिला नथिंग वी गॉट राइट तो यहां पे हमें
कुछ यहां पे मिला नहीं है अब देखो यहां पे
हान v हमने ये चीज कर ली अब
अब अब यहां हम क्या कर सकते हैं यहां पे
आप ओएस डिटेक्शन भी कर सकते हैं ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम डिटेक्शन हाइन ओ लगा के या तो आप
हाइन ए लगाएंगे तो आप ओएस डिटेक्शन वर्जन
डिटेक्शन स्क्रिप्ट स्कैनिंग ट्रेस रूट सब
एक साथ कर लेंगे सब कुछ एक साथ हान ए एकदम
ऑल इन वन है तो कोई हान ए लगाना है हान ए
लगा लो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक है वो आप
लगा सकते हो उसके बाद अब बात करते हैं
पोर्ट के स्कैनिंग के लिए मान लो कोई एक
पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट को स्कैन करना हो आपको
रेंज ऑफ पोर्ट को स्कैन करना हो तो आप यह
पोर्ट स्पेसिफिकेशन ऑप्शंस को यूज कर सकते
हैं इसके बाद यहां
पे स्कैन टेक्निक्स में आप जो स्कैन
टेक्निक्स चाहे यूज कर सकते हैं वो आपकी
मर्जी है फिलहाल हम कोई यूज नहीं कर रहे
हैं हम पोर्ट के लिए जरूर स्पेसिफाई
करेंगे कि कौन सा पोर्ट स्कैनिंग हमको यूज
करना है तो हम यहां पे पोर्ट स्कैनिंग
करते हैं तो यहां पे आप टॉप पोर्ट्स के
लिए हाइफान हाइफान टॉप पोर्ट्स लगा सकते
हैं अगर आपको चाहिए कि अ लाइक काइंड ऑफ
एक रेंज ऑफ पोर्ट को स्कैन करना है तो आप
रेंज ऑफ पोर्ट ऐसे स्कैन कर सकते हैं इस
तरीके से देखिए यहां पे हान प एंड उसके
बाद जो भी आपको रेंज देना है वो आप रेंज
दे दीजिए ठीक है वो आपकी मर्जी है तो जैसे
अगर मैं यहां पर रेंज दे देता हूं जैसे
मैं यहां पर क्या कर देता
हूं हान एस ब लगा दिया यहां पे सर्विस
वर्जन के लिए हाइन प एंड यहां पर मैं रेंज
दे देता हूं जीरो से लेकर 65000
55 य पूरा मैं रेंज देता हूं सारे ही
पोर्ट्स के लिए
65535 तो मैं जब एंटर करूंगा तो यह सारे
ही पोर्ट के लिए मैं य पर पीएन लगा देता
हूं ताकि
यह होस्ट डिस्कवरी ना करे तो अब य होस्ट
डिस्कवरी डिसेबल आ रहा
है अब ये देखिए होस्ट डिस्कवरी य आरहा
डिबल आ रहा
है क्योंकि हमने डिबल किया प ल एड्रेसस
विल बी मार्क्ड अप एंड स्कैन टाइम मे बी
स्लोअर अब ये अप इसलिए सबको कर देगा
क्योंकि सबको स्कैन करेगा सारे पोर्ट्स के
लिए सीधी सधी बात है तो क्योंकि ओबवियसली
आ जितने भी पोर्ट्स है सबके लिए स्कैन कर
रहा है 65536 पोर्ट्स यहां प आप देख रहे
होंगे यहां पर आप एंटर करेंगे तो यह 0.29
पर स्टिल स्कैनिंग कर रहा है
अभी सिन स्टेल्थ स्कैन टाइमिंग दिखा रहा
है आपको
ये ये स्कैनिंग कर रहा है फिलहाल के लिए
सस
वेट सर अगर मैं साइबेरी से सिर्फ वेब
एप्लीकेशन पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टिंग का कोर्स
कर लूं तो क्या मैं बग बाउंट कर सकता हूं
देखो मुझे एगजैक्टली मैं नहीं बता सकता कि
उसमें क्या कंटेंट है मुझे कंटेंट का नहीं
पता है अगर कंटेंट अच्छा है अगर बढ़िया
टॉपिक्स है सब कुछ है है तो यू कैन
डेफिनेटली गो फॉर दैट मुझे उसका ज्यादा
आईडिया नहीं है अदर वाइज आप बग बाउटी की
हमारी सीरीज को कंटिन्यू कीजिए इसमें सब
आपको मिल जाएगा एवरीथिंग यू विल गेट ठीक
है एंड प्लीज डोंट स्पैम फरहाना अहमद
प्लीज आप स्पैम मत कीजिए ठीक है तो यहां
पे ये स्कैनिंग चल रही है यहां पे ये 1 पर
आपको दिख रहा होगा यहां पे कि स्कैनिंग
में यहां पे आपको दिखा रहा है एंड जो भी
आपको रिजल्ट होगा फिर आपको सामने जो है वो
मिल जाएगा सिंपल सा फंडा है
ठीक है प्लीज आप लोग स्पैम मत कीजिए इट्स
अ रिक्वेस्ट टू एवरी
बडी
प्लीज ठीक
है ओके सो यहां पे 1.21 पर है यहां प 1.68
इट विल टेक टाइम सम टाइम तो उतना टाइम हम
नहीं देते हैं यहां प फिलहाल मैं इसको
क्लोज कर देता हूं मैं आपको इसका एक लाइव
एग्जांपल एक वर्किंग एग्जांपल भी दिखा
देता हूं ताकि आपको समझ में आ जाए ठीक है
कि एक्चुअली इसका यूज हम कैसे करेंगे
चलिए तो मैं यहां पर अपने काली मशीन पर
हूं
एंड मैं यहां पर मेटा स् पलटेबल को ऑन कर
लेता
हूं आई होप कि यह भी ब्रिज में ही
है नेट में यह लेट्स डू लेट्स शिफ्ट इट टू
ब्रिज लेट्स पावर ऑन द मेटा स्टेबल मशीन
तो मैं क्या कर रहा हूं मैं अपने मेटा
स्टेबल मशीन को चालू कर रहा हूं जो कि एक
वल्नरेबल इंटेंशनली वल्नरेबल मशीन है और
एक मेरे पास काली है ठीक है काली अगर मैं
आपको आईपी
दिखाऊं तो यह आईपी है 19210
और ये मे टस्ट प टेबल ऑन हो रहा
है चलिए यहां पे आ गए हम यहां लॉगइन कर
लेते हैं एमएसएफ एडमिन एमएसएफ एडमिन कर
दिया हमने क्लियर अब यहां पे आईएफ कॉन्फिन
पे तो आईबी इसकी है 183 183 है काली से
पिंग करके देख लो सही सब कुछ है ना तो
पिंग
192.168
2913 एंड पिंग हो रहा है ओबवियसली सब कुछ
चल रहा है अब हम इसको एज अ अटैकर मशीन
मानेंगे काली हमारा और यह जो हमारा मेट स्
पलाइट है यह हमारा क्या है यह हमारा
विक्टिम मशीन है मान लो तो अब मैं एम का
सिंपल सा यूज़ केस बता देता हूं न एवी
सर्विस डिटेक्शन करूंगा
192.168
2913 जो हमारा विक्टिम मशीन है यह काम मैं
करूंगा और मैं यहां पे हान पीएन होस्ट
डिस्कवरी डिसेबल कर देता हूं क्योंकि इसका
कोई भी काम नहीं है उसके बाद हान
t5 t3 ही रहने देते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं
लोकल में है एंड ट्स इट बस इतना ही करना
है इससे ज्यादा तो कुछ करना नहीं है और
एंटर करते हैं अब
देखिए जस्ट
वेट ए मैप चल रहा है यहां पे ए मैप जैसे
ही चला हमें यहां पर रिजल्ट रिस मिल गए और
रिजल्ट्स में हमें क्या मिल रहे हैं गाइस
देखो यहां पे हमें रिजल्ट्स में यहां पर
मिले हैं कि यह सारे पोर्ट्स ओपन है ऑल
दीस पोर्ट्स आर ओपन ऑल दस पोर्ट्स आर
ब्रिज इसलिए किया कि सेम नेटवर्क सेम
उसमें आ जाए ना एडाप्टर हमारा सेम हो जाए
एल ठीक है तो यहां पे यहां पे रिजल्ट्स
मिल रहे हैं अब इसमें यहां पे एक वर्जन
मिला हमें सर्विस की एफटीपी की एफटीपी की
वीएस एफटीपीडी
2.3.4 अब ये जो वीएस एफटीपीडी 2.3.4 है ये
जो ये जो हैय एक वल्नरेबल सर्विस है ठीक
है वल्नरेबल सर्विस ध्यान दीजिए इधर ये एक
वल्नरेबल सर्विस है जिसको कि हम
एक्सप्लोइट कर सकते हैं अब मान लो इससे
रिलेटेड एक्सप्लोइट हम सर्च करेंगे तो हम
क्या
करेंगे स एस
एफटीपीडी
एक्सप्लोइट ऐसे सर्च करेंगे तो हमें
अलग-अलग एक्सप्लोइट मिलेंगे ऊपर के तीन
चार पाच जो भी रिजल्ट है उसको ओपन कर
लीजिए यहां पर ये एक्सप्लोइट है एक यहां
पे नीचे आ जाइए यहां पे आ जाते हैं यहां
पे एक एक्सप्लॉयड यहां पे हमें मिला एंड
ये देख के हमें पता चल रहा है कि एक मेटा
एक्सप्लॉयड का एक्सप्लॉयड है मिट स्पॉइल
इट है यानी कि जो यहां पे हमें नीचे आ
जाते हैं और भी रैपिड सेवन की भी मिल रही
है
क्या
टा यहां पे हमें देखने से ये पता चल रहा
है कि एक मेटास्प्लोइटेबल
मेटा स्पॉट में ये ऑलरेडी एक्सप्लोइट है
अवेलेबल है आप इसको मेटा स् पलट से
एक्सप्लोइट कर सकते हो सिंपल सा फंडा है
तो मेटा स्प्लैट से एक्सप्लोइट हम कैसे
करेंगे भैया इधर देख
लीजिए ओके तो मैं यहां पे फरहान अहमद को
बैन कर रहा हूं 24 आवर्स के लिए क्योंकि
इनका स्पैमिंग रुक नहीं रहा है इवन आफ्टर
सेइंग रिपीटेडली सो एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी बट
मुझे करना पड़ेगा
धन्यवाद
फरान जी आपको जाना पड़ेगा आज के सेशन से
मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट सेशन में आप बार-बार वह
कर रहे हैं स्पैम कर रहे हैं तो मेरे पास
कोई और ऑप्शन बचा नहीं है ठीक है
धन्यवाद चलिए तो यहां पर फरहान जो है इनको
यहां पर मैं कर देता हूं टाइम आउट एंड
अगले 30 मिनट के लिए टाइम आउट कर देते हैं
कन्फर्म ठीक है चलिए अब इनका स्पैम नहीं
आएगा अब इनका स्पैम गया बढ़िया अब यहां प
हम प्रैक्टिकल देख रहे हैं यहां पे ध्यान
दीजिए इधर आप लोग सभी लोग प्लीज तो यहां प
मेट स्प्ड का एक मॉड्यूल है अब मेट स्प्ड
का अगर आपको नहीं है नॉलेज तो प्लीज आप
थोड़ा सा पढ़िए अदर वाइज हम तो खैर लेके
आएंगे सब कुछ तो अब यहां पे हमें मिल चुका
अ वीएसएफटीपीडी अब हम यहां सर्च करेंगे कि
वीएसएफटीपीडी का कोई एक्सप्लोइट पब्लिकली
अवेलेबल है क्या तो सर्च स्प्ड से
वीएसएफटीपीडी एंटर करेंगे तो आपको
वीएसएफटीपीडी का 2.3.4 का बैकडोर कमांड
एग्जीक्यूशन मेटा स्पल का यहां पे आपको
मिल रहा है तो यह अवेलेबल तो है भाई तो
चलो अब एक काम करते हैं अब मेटास पलट में
घुसते हैं एमएसएफ कंसोल के थ्रू एमएसएफ
कंसोल के थ्रू हम इसके अंदर घुस जाते हैं
एंड यहां पे देखेंगे तो कैसे आपको करना है
यह कौन सा है यहां
पे एफटीपी के अंदर में वीएस एफटीपीडी बैक
डोर का एक् स्पॉट है जिसको कि हम यूज कर
सकते हैं तो चलिए तो मेटा स्पॉट हमारा
स्टार्ट हो चुका
है धन्यवाद धन्यवाद अरे कितने
सब्सक्राइबर्स हो गए भाई हमारे देखा ही
नहीं यार कितने हो गए टोटल अभी तक ये कैसे
पता
चलेगा आई थिंक इधर से पता चलेगा
अच्छा लाइव तो कंप्लीट नहीं पता चलेगा
यह 10 के तो शायद नहीं हुए है ना 997 दिखा
रहा है लेट्स रिड 9.98 है अच्छा मैं वैसे
देख लेता हूं ना मोबाइल पे मोबाइल से तो
दिख ही जाएगा कितना हुआ है कितने
सब्सक्राइबर हो गए हमारे
9984 9984 हो गए हैं भाई
15 16 की कमी और 10000 हमारे पास डिफर हो
जाएंगे क्या बात है क्या बात
है क्या बात है भाई
चलिए अरे रेवेन्यू तो अभी $100 भी नहीं
हुए हैं रेवेन्यू अभी $ भी नहीं हुए हैं
हो जाएंगे तो मैं बताऊंगा टेंशन मत लो ठीक
है तो यहां पे होने होंगे जल्दी होंगे
लेकिन अभी नहीं हुए अब मैं यहां पे क्लियर
करके ऊपर आ जाता हूं अब मैं यहां पे सर्च
करता हूं सर्च ठीक है सर्च करूंगा क्या वी
एस एफ एटी पडी तो मैं सर्च जब करूंगा तो
मुझे यहां पर एक एक्सप्लोइट दिखेगा
एक्सप्लोइट यहां पर यह आपको दिख रहा होगा
यक्स एफटीपी वीएस एटी 234 बैक डोर देखो ए
मैप का यूज किस तरीके से हो रहा है हमने
सर्विस डिटेक्ट किया एक पर्टिकुलर टारगेट
पे एंड उस सर्विस पर हमें एक ओल्ड सर्विस
मिला एफटीपी का जो वल्नरेबल है
एक्सप्लोइटेबल है मेट पलट नाम के
फ्रेमवर्क से हम ट्राई कर रहे हैं टू
एक्सप्लोइट ट बस ट्स इट
देखो अब हम इस एक्सप्लोइट को यूज कर कैसे
यूज करेंगे तो यूज एक्सप्लोइट जिनको नहीं
आता मेट एक्सप्लोइट प्लीज आप थोड़ा सा देख
लीजिएगा मेट एक्सप्लोइट का कि क्या हो रहा
है यहां पे अदर वाइज जब हम सेशन लेकर
आएंगे मेट एक्सप्लोइट का सेपरेट तो आपको
समझ में आ जाएगा ठीक है यूज एक्सप्लोइट
यक्स
एफटीपी वीएस एफटीपीडी बैक डोर हम इसको यूज
कर रहे हैं ठीक है बढ़िया अब यहां पे
हमारा कोई पेलोड हमने सेट नहीं किया है तो
डिफॉल्ट पलट सीएमडी यक्स इंटरेक्ट आ चुका
है इसका परफेक्ट अब यहां पे शो इंफो
करेंगे तो आपको इस पट ल एक्सप्लोइट की
पूरी डिटेल आएगी कि एक्सप्लोइट का नाम
क्या है मॉड्यूल क्या है प्लेटफॉर्म कौन
सा है आर्किटेक्चर सीएमडी प्रिविलेज यस
प्रिविलेज आपको रूट प्रिविलेज मिल जाएगी
यहां पे लाइसेंस आपको मिल जाएगा
प्रोवाइडेड बाय जो प्रोवाइडर है इनके वो
मिल जाएगा एंड यह डिटेल्स आपके सामने होके
आ जाएंगी अब यहां पे हमने क्या किया शो
इंफो अब चलिए अब यहां पे मैं यहां पर लाइव
में आ गया हूं ना भाई लाइव अच्छा हां चलिए
अब यहां पर गाइस शो इंफो आपने किया तो
यहां पे अब मैं क्या कर देता हूं एक और
करता हूं शो ऑप्शंस जब मैं एंटर करूंगा तो
यहां पे ये ऑप्शन शो करेगा कि इसमें
क्या-क्या चीजें आप कंफिल आपको करनी है
व्हाट थिंग्स यू कैन कंफिल यहां पे तो आर
होस्ट यानी रिमोट होस्ट जिसको आप टारगेट
जो आपका है उसका आईपी एड्रेस डालना है तो
यहां पे हमें सेट करना है क्या करना है आर
होस्ट रिमोट होस्ट यानी रिमोट अरे यार ये
पॉज कैसे हो जा रहा है हम तो यहां पे हमें
आर होस्ट सेट करना है रिमोट होस्ट जो
हमारा टारगेट है आर पोट 21 ही होगा एफटीपी
के लिए
दैट्ची
192.168
29.1
दैट्ची है यही हमारा टारगेट है अब चलिए अब
हमने इतना कुछ कर लिया
दैट्ची लि हो गई सारी एलस करने पर कमांड य
चल गई य लिस्ट अब मैं यहां पर आपको दिखा
देता हूं मैं य पर शेल कमांड चलाता हूं
एंटर करता हूं जैसे ही मैं शेल कमांड
चलाऊंगा यहां पर फाउंड बैश शल बिन स् बश
अब जो है आपके पास एक रूट रेट मेट प्टेबल
की शेल आ चुकी है एंड यह हमारे विक्टिम
मशीन की है क्योंकि जब आप आईएफ कॉन्फो
सॉरी सॉरी अरे
भैया क्योंकि जब आप आईएफ कॉन्फिन पर
देखोगे तो आपको आईपी दिखेगी 192
9.13 जो कि हमारे इस पर्टिकुलर मेटा स्पल
टेबल
की सो सो वी आर वी आर इनटू द मेटा
एक्सप्लोइट मटा एक्सप्लोइटेबल जो हमारी
विक्टिम मशीन है 10 के हो गए क्या भाई अरे
सच में क्या लेट्स रिड इट अभी तो यहां
दिखा नहीं रहा है बट शायद हो गए होंगे मे
बी
डेनिक्स
अभी तो नहीं हुए
होंगे अभी नहीं हुए हैं तो हो जाएंगे
जल्दी हो जाएंगे टेंशन मत लो जल्दी होंगे
ज्यादा टाइम नहीं लगेगा तो हम यहां पे
क्या हम क्या यहां पे क्या क्या हो चुके
हैं यहां पे हम यहां पे उस बेसिकली
विक्टिम मशीन के अंदर जा चुके हैं अब इसका
टेस्ट भी कर लेते हैं जैसे मैं यहां पे
एलएस करता हूं तो मेरे को यह सारी फाइल्स
मिल रही है ये एलएस करने पे ये सारी
फाइल्स मिल रही है ठीक है तो मैं यहां पे
सीडी कमांड से रूट में चला जाता हूं
सीडी क्या हो रहा है
ये हां चलिए मैं रूट में आ चुका अब मैं
यहां एलएस करता हूं तो यहां पे मुझे एक
फाइल मिल रही है डेस्कटॉप वीएनसी लॉग ऐसे
मिल रही है चलो मैं अपने यहां पे विक्टिम
मशीन प चलता हूं एंड विक्टिम मशीन पे यहां
पे
सीडी यहां पे एलस करता हूं तो आप यहां पे
एक सीडी स्ल रूट में चलते हैं एंड यहां
एलएस करते हैं तो यहां पे डेस्कटॉप रिसेट
लॉग एवीसी डलॉग ये आ गई सेम चीज अब मैं
यहां पर अपने अटैकर मशीन से एक फोल्डर बना
देता हूं या एक फाइल बना देता हूं एक
फोल्डर चलो एक फोल्डर बना देते हैं या
फाइल ही बना लो यार विम विम चलेगा क्या
देखते हैं
विम यहां मैं
सब्सक्राइब डि फ्रक्स डटी एकटी एंड यहां
पर मैं लेता
हूं
सब्सक्राइब टू डि फोनिक्स अकेडमी
ट्स
इट कोलन अरे भैया अब इससे तो बाहर निकलना
भी मुश्किल है
यार चलो मैं यहां
से यस कर देता हूं बाहर निकल जाता हूं
यहां से यह बाहर निकल गए यहां से वापस
एक्सप्लोइट कर लेते एक बार कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है ऑलरेडी
ओपन ओके तो मैं यहां पे सेशंस लिख देता
हूं यहां पे सेशंस अगर है तो सेशंस नहीं
है यहां पे चलिए अच्छी बात है कोई टेंशन
नहीं है मैं यहां पे फिर से एक्सप्लोइट कर
देता
हूं ऑलरेडी ओपन ओके ऑलरेडी ओपन है इसलिए
मैं यहां पे काम कर देता हूं मैं यहां पे
डन डन डन डन डन डन चलिए यहां पर फिर से एक
बार ओपन कर लेते हैं जल्दी से
फटाफट
[संगीत]
टाटाटा यस यस थारा भाई योगेंदर वैसे मैं
करने वाला था लेकिन यस आपने भी किया था तो
मैं आपका क्रेडिट नहीं छीन टेंशन नहीं
लेना आपको ठीक है यूज एक्सप्लोइट यून एक
सेफ्टी पीडी वी एस सेफ्टी पीडी न यहां पे
मैं कर देता हूं यहां पे
सेट आर होस्ट
192.168
29.1 फ शो ऑप्शन मैं जल्दी जल्दी कर दे
रहा हूं क्योंकि ऑलरेडी हो चुका था यहां
पर एक्सप्लोइट कर देते हैं और एंटर करते
हैं यहां पर ऑलरेडी कोड यूज हो रहा
है ओ सर्विस पोट ऑलरेडी यूज हो रहा है ट्स
वाई तो यहां पर
मैं
कौन सा स एक बार जस्ट वेट गाइस जस्ट वेट
जस्ट वेट जस्ट
वेट यह रहा यह वाला यूज हो रहा है इसकी पी
आईडी क्या है अ पी आईडी यह वाली है पी
आईडी 28
9563 तो
किल 28 सॉरी 28
9563 पी आईडी कौन सी थी भाई इसकी पी आईडी
यही तो है ना और क्या है हां पी आईडी सही
है तो गई ना अब तो भाई पी
आईडी फिर से आ
जाओ
यह अभी भी आ रहा है क्या आ रहा है 28
9563 किल
2896 2895
63 अच्छा रुको इनको मैं इनको मैं थोड़ा सा
साइड करता
हूं इनको भी मैं टाइम आउट में डाल देता
हूं इनको क्या कर सकते हैं बच्चों वाली
चीज आप मत सीखो यार
अरे मत करो यार अलग-अलग यह फेक अकाउंट से
सब्सक्राइब मत करो प्लीज इट्स रिक्वेस्ट
जेनन आने दो जेनन आने दो प्लीज प्लीज जेनन
आने दो प्लीज इट्स रिक्वेस्ट गाइस ठीक है
रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं
आपसे यहां पर यहां पर मैं यहां पर काम
करता हूं मैं यहां पर इट कहां गया भैया
हमारा मेटा स्प
डेबल ये रहा हमारा मेटा स्प डेबल
रिबूट सूडो
रिबूट एमएसएफ
एडमिन चलिए यहां ट
[संगीत]
ट
चलिए मैंने यहां पर एक बार इसको रिबूट कर
लिया फटाक से प्लीज एंड आप लोग प्लीज फेक
अकाउंट हा मतलब ऐसे जबरदस्ती वाला मत करना
यार आप लोग वो सब्सक्राइब उसको ऑटोमेटिक
आने दो ना जो जो ओरिजिनल जो आने का जो
खुशी होती है वो ऐसे जबरदस्ती वाली में
नहीं होती है आपका ही अकाउंट है ठीक अच्छी
बात है बट व तो एक्टिव नहीं रहेगा ना
एक्टिव नहीं रहेगा ना व इसलिए राइट सो
प्लीज ठीक है चलिए यहां पर हमारा खाली बूट
हो चुका है मैं य पर लॉगइन कर लेता हूं
टेबल में लॉगइन कर लेता
हूं ओके तो 10 एमएसएफ एडमिन एमएसएफ एडमिन
एंड वी आर लगड
इन सीडी
[संगीत]
रूट एलस
चलिए यहां पर आ चुके हम काली में भी आ ही
चुके
हैं धन्यवाद भाई धन्यवाद ऑलमोस्ट 10 के
होने वाले
हैं एंड हम इस 10 के को सेलिब्रेट यहीं पर
कर लेंगे लग रहा है पहली पहले आपके साथ ही
हो जाएगी यह सेलिब्रेशन मेरे ख्याल से
चलिए एमएसएफ
कंसोल पहले ही हो जाएगा मेरे ख्याल
से
चलिए यहां पे आ चुके हैं यहां पे एंड
लेट्स लेट्स कनेक्ट तो सिंपल सा फंडा था
हमारा क्या था कि यूज
एक्सप्लोइट यक्स के अंदर में एफटीपी के
अंदर में वीएस एफटीपीडी बैक डोर करना था
यहां पे यहां पे शो ऑप्शंस कर लेते हैं
यहां पे सेट आर होस्ट कर लेते हैं एंड यह
हम कर लेते हैं
192.168 2.13 हमारा टारगेट था और हम हम
इसको एक्सप्लोइट कर लेते हैं जैसे हम
एक्सप्लोइट करेंगे यहां पर ऑलरेडी यहां पर
आप देख सकते हैं कि यह सेशन फाउंड हो चुका
है यहां पर शेल कमांड डालिए आपको एक सेशन
मिल
जाएगी एंड यस फाउंड बिन बैश एंड यू गट द
मटर मेट पॉट का जो बन बैस्ट शेल है वो
आपको मिल चुका है यहां पे एंड अब जो है आप
बेसिकली यहां पे मैं सीडी करके रूट में
चला जाता हूं रूट डायरेक्टरी में चला जाता
हूं सॉरी सीडी स् रूट एंड मैं यहां पे
एलएस करता हूं सॉरी
सीडी स्ल रूट क्या हुआ हां रूट में आ चुके
हैं यहां पे अब मैं एलएस करूंगा यहां पे
ये सारी फाइल्स है अब मैं यहां पे एमकेडी
आईआर एंड यहां पे बना देता हूं एक हैकर
नाम का
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
हमने इस मशीन को कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया
मेटास पलटेबल को कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर लिया एंड
यही तो बात है भाई यही तो इंटरेस्टिंग चीज
है कि हमने एक मशीन को सिर्फ एन मैप के
स्कैनिंग के थ्रू हमने पता किया भैया कि
भैया यह कौन सा सर्विस चल रहा है वल्नरेबल
है कि नहीं है क्या कर सकते हैं हम उस
मशीन में घुस गए दैट्ची तो आपको करना है
भाई यही तो आपको करना है ए मैप में जिनको
नहीं समझ में आ रहा था ना कि ए मैप में
क्या करना है यही तो करना है जो मैंने अभी
आपको बताया सिंपल यह बात आप सबको समझ में
आ गई है यह सब क्लियर हो चुका है इतना
बहुत ही सिंपल सा फंडा था क्लियर हो चुका
सभी
को हां तो यहां पे मैं
[संगीत]
दिखाऊ क्या चलो यहां पे एनालिटिक्स पे चल
देते हैं एंड एनालिटिक्स पे चलके
डायरेक्टली यहां पे लाइव काउंट सो यहां पे
9997 सब्सक्राइबर्स हमारे हो चुके हैं वी
आर गोइंग टू अचीव 10000 सब्सक्राइबर मार्क
वेरी सून बहुत जल्दी ये हो जाएगा तीन बस
बचे हुए हैं यह अपने आप हो ही जाएगा अ
थोड़ी देर में मे बी शायद से तो इट्स अ
वेरी अ अ प्राउड मूवमेंट फॉर अस गाइ है ना
एंड मैं इसका फोटो भी ले लूंगा जब यह हो
जाएगा तो सो बस
यही आजकल गेमिंग गेमिंग वीडियोस क्या
गेमिंग वीडियोस यार यस ब बढ़िया अगर
क्लियर हो
गया तो देखते हैं कब तक यह होता है वैसे
तो हमारे ना 997 हो चुके हैं कोई दिक्कत
नहीं
है धन्यवाद आप सभी का गाइस 999 हो चुका है
एंड मैं विंडोज प्रिंट स्क्रीन बटन बटन जो
है वो उसी पर हाथ है मेरा मैं स्क्रीनशॉट
ले लूंगा जैसे
ही हमारा 10 के हो जाएगा सो लेट्स
सी सो इट्स अ वेरी वेरी वेरी हैप्पी
मूमेंट बिकॉज हम जीरो से यहां तक पहुंचे
हैं एंड ट्स इट गाइस ट्स इट ट्स ट वी आर
नाउ हैविंग 10000 सब्सक्राइबर मार्क्सस ऑन
डेनिक्स अकेडमी
youtube4 मेंट है इस चैनल के लिए सो एंड
आप सब की वजह से हुआ है लिटरली बता रहा
हूं एक-एक बंदा जो यहां पे इस चैनल पे है
प्रेजेंट उन सब की वजह से हुआ है एंड आई
एम वेरी थैंकफूल टू एवरीवन ईच वन ऑफ यू
दिल से थैंक्स बोल रहा हूं आप सबको इसलिए
क्योंकि आपका सपोर्ट मिला है और ऐसी ही
क्वालिटी कंटेंट आपको मैं देता जाऊंगा
आपको मिलती जाएगी इस बात की गारंटी भी मैं
आपको आज देता हूं हमारे 10000 सब्सक्राइबर
मार्क पे एंड ट्राई हैक मी का वाउचर का
गिव अवे का रिजल्ट ट भी शायद कल या परसों
आपको मिल जाएगी तो बेफिकर रहिए थैंक यू सो
मच दिल से मजा आ गया है ना तो आप सब इसके
लाइव आप सबने लाइव यह देखा है यू आर
लाइव इसके क्या गवाह 10000 सब्सक्राइबर्स
के एंड दिस इज समथिंग वेरी वेरी अमेजिंग
गाइस दिस इज रियली अमेजिंग रियली दिल से
मतलब क्या बोलू मैं
यार इट्स रियली अमेजिंग थैंक यू गाइस थैंक
यू एवरीवन ईच वन ऑफ यू थैंक यू सो मच थैंक
यू थैंक यू पल्लव थैंक यू तन्या थैंक यू
अरुण राज थैंक यू थैंक
यू पंकज थैंक यू हैकर रितिक सबको धन्यवाद
ट्यूटोरियल हैक धन्यवाद धन्यवाद सबको
विक्रम थैंक यू विक्रम शिनोबी थैंक यू ठीक
है हा मेरा एफर्ट तो है लेकिन आपका सपोर्ट
भी है मेरा एफर्ट भी है दोनों मिलकर ही यह
हुआ है मेरा एफर्ट एंड आपका सपोर्ट दोनों
मिलकर हम इस मार्क पर पहुंचे
हैं
चश्मा लगाइए ना चश्मा है नहीं यार मेरे
पास में एंड इस
पे केक कटिंग तो बनती है गाना बजाऊंगा तो
पता है ना कॉपीराइट आ जाएगा
तुरंत चलिए अब अब 10000 से नेक्स्ट हमारा
टारगेट जो है ना वो 50000 का हम रखते हैं
25000 का रखते हैं चलो 50 बहुत ज्यादा हो
जाता है 25000 का रखते हैं एंड आई होप कि
आप वो भी बहुत जल्दी इस चैनल को उस तक
लेकर जरूर जाएंगे 110 पर 110 पर लेकर
जाएंगे
एंड
एंड हम उस माइलस्टोन को भी जल्दी ही
पकड़ने वाले हैं ठीक है धन्यवाद गाइस आप
सबका एंड आज के सेशन का हमने अगर मैं
ओवरव्यू आपको
दूं थैंक
यू थैंक यू चलिए ओवर ओवरव्यू
दूं तो हमने क्या
किया डिटेल
एन मैप को पढ़ा हमने डिटेल एन मैप को हमने
यहां
पे होस्ट डिस्कवरी करी हमने यहां पे पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग
करी हमने यहां
पे सर्विस
एंड वर्जन डिटेक्शन
किया एंड हमने क्या किया एक्सप्लोइट किया
यह सब कुछ किया लेकिन इसके पार्ट टू यानी
नेक्स्ट क्लास में हम और भी डीप जाने वाले
हैं एन मैप वाले इस चीज के ऊपर में और भी
जो हमारी सर्विस एंड वर्जन डिटेक्शन है
इसका ओवरव्यू आपको आज मिला है इस को और भी
ज्यादा डीप लेकर जाने वाले हैं और भी
इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें आपको मिलने वाली है तो
नेक्स्ट क्लास में जरूर प्रेजेंट रहिएगा
एंड ट्राई हैक मी वाले जो टास्क दिया है
उसको जरूर कर लीजिएगा
कंप्लीट ठीक
है बताएंगे बताएंगे स्क्रिप्ट वगैरह सब
आएगा वही तो बोल रहा हू ना एक पार्ट टू
में अभी और भी इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें आने वाली
है भैया पार्ट टू में आप जरूर आइएगा पार्ट
टू में हम और भी डीप जाएंगे और भी बहुत
कुछ करने वाले हैं इसका जो पार्ट टू सेशन
आएगा उसको जरूर देखिएगा लाइव स्ट्रीम जब
होगी तो इसका पार्ट टू भी आएगा क्योंकि ये
जो है एनम फर बर्क बाउंट पार्ट वन है
पार्ट टू नेक्स्ट क्लास में होगी जिसमें
हम इसमें जो भी चीजें और बची है जैसे एप
की स्क्रिप्टिंग इंजन के बारे में बात हो
गई या अ एप के कुछ फायरवॉल बाईपास
टेक्निक्स की बात हो गई या फिर हम एन मैप
की अ कुछ डेटा लेंथ वगैरह की बात करें
एमटी पैकेट्स की बात करें उसकी बात हो गई
एंड एप से और भी बग बाउंटीज में क्या कुछ
कर सकते हैं कितना हम एफर्ट हम लाइफ
टारगेट को सर्विस डिटेक्शन के लिए फाइंड
आउट करेंगे ट्राई करेंगे उन परे हंट करने
का एंड ट्राई करेंगे सर्विसेस फाइंड करने
का एंड कुछ यूसी इंफॉर्मेशन निकालने का ये
सब पार्ट टू में होने वाला है तो पार्ट टू
को बिल्कुल मिस नहीं करना है नेक्स्ट
क्लास में आपकी होगी एंड आज के इस सेशन के
लिए बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद एंड इतने लोग आए
हैं वेरी वेरी थैंक यू फॉर
एवरीबॉडी जो भी यहां प्रेजेंट है और जो
नहीं है प्रेजेंट उनको भी थैंक यू इस 10
के सब्सक्राइबर मार्क तक हमें पहुंचाने के
लिए
धन्यवाद 100 के सून थैंक यू थैंक
यू चलिए ओके गाइस सो आज के सेशन को यहां
पे एंड करते हैं एंड सबको गुड नाइट बाय
बाय टेक केयर
पे सारी अपडेट्स आपको आती है टाइमिंग से
रिलेटेड ठीक है